five four three two
hello hello everybody it's Monday
November
21st it is Thanksgiving week and here we
are gobble gobble any other show would
have taken the whole week off
but us
we live for this we nigh for this game
if he looks upset you wanna you don't
want to be here at me no no I just this
is my little office look at the camera I
do all the time
fussy he's doing the cute little gym
thing yeah
you don't get to decide to be gym helper
you know what I mean and you can't just
look at the camera for no reason it's
became it's become my thing the audience
likes it
so that means you don't want to be here
for Thanksgiving no I would love to be
here for Thanksgiving I hate my family
you're my family right okay fair enough
I love you too you're my family also
[ __ ] I do like my family though but
you're part of it thank you
welcome guys welcome welcome November
21st yeah so today uh this week first of
all Happy Thanksgiving week a lot of
people probably have no school this week
my son doesn't
a lot of people might be off work and um
we're having a little bit of an unusual
week we're going to be here Monday
Wednesday
Thursday's Thanksgiving we're going to
be posting our thanks annual
Thanksgiving special
you laugh you lose
um it's a fan classic it's a fan
favorite last year it was so much fun
and we're gonna be doing again this
Thursday so stay tuned Friday we will
not be here we will be celebrating
Thanksgiving with our family we were
going to post it on Friday actually oh
Friday okay Friday yeah so there'll be
episodes Monday Wednesday Friday okay
got it got it got it Friday Okay cool so
Friday there that'll be there and um
I'm excited Sam Sam is preparing she's
downstairs yes Sam is preparing like
last year she prepares horrid disgusting
Thanksgiving dishes can't wait that you
have to eat from if you lose and last
year it was pretty brutal I'm not gonna
lie it was the The Mint peppermint
mashed potatoes I was about to say that
one yes I can still taste it a year
later you know it really scarred me you
wouldn't expect it right it was so
[ __ ] fat bro I think she put a lot of
that extract in there it was just not
right yeah yeah yeah
but anyway so looking forward to this
week's yeah Happy Thanksgiving everybody
oh people are so will there be a see you
next Tuesday this week there will be a
see you next Tuesday tomorrow live
of course there will be are you crazy
you think I could Elite the only reason
I would ever not leave you guys on that
is if I'm [ __ ] banned and physically
can't or if my uh or or if I'm in a coma
or dead
you understand me Dan so you're
recording two episodes tomorrow then
no tomorrow oh yeah [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah I
will [ __ ] it after that better yeah
because we're pre-recording the
Thanksgiving special tomorrow
oh [ __ ]
just over committing myself oh you know
what I could do you know what I could do
is maybe I can do a
maybe I can do one on [ __ ]
Saturday or Sunday
I gotta do it I gotta do it I gotta
figure it out what type of recording on
uh tomorrow well whenever you like come
in so maybe I can do it maybe I'll do
the live at like 12 for an hour and then
we can record here at two
is that too late in the day I just don't
know if I believe you that you're gonna
do that I'll do it I'll do it not just
on that schedule not that you won't do
it at all but that I mean cam says I can
just pre-record it tonight that's that's
not a bad idea I like doing the lives
but maybe just I gotta do one
pre-recorded tonight yeah for um
for Thanksgiving we can all get back to
doing it live by the way thank you Derek
runz for the 50 gifted sub we love it
the legend the Run we love you Derek
yeah so there will be a see you next
Tuesday
tomorrow for all of our wonderful
members who support us so graciously
makes such a big difference we love you
guys I'm actually going to experiment
with a new format tomorrow now obviously
I don't have time to do like mad
preparation but I do love true
crime and I've been wanting to do that
so I'm thinking I'm gonna make an
episode tomorrow on the Golden State
killer one of my favorite serial killers
was recently resolved in the most crazy
way this is one of the most fascinating
True Crime cases of all time dude crazy
[ __ ] as tears serial killer for sure
well the stories unbelie the guy was so
vicious such a NE he was the he's
probably the most psychotic depraved
freak on the planet and the way they
caught him was just unbelievable so
that's a great one and um I'm gonna I'm
gonna talk about that tomorrow and see
how that goes with zero preparation
probably just reading the Wikipedia page
let's be real
wow what can I do I don't I can't prep
for it
no I'll do a little more than that
just a joke by the way thank you to the
oh God this Arrow doesn't work thank you
Elon with a shirt for 10 gifted and
thank you to the main Broski for five
gifted y'all are two doing too much out
there
yeah he's he's my fav serial killer I
mean he is he's the most he's your
favorite huh he's the best he's my
favorite murderer you know I'm more of a
Richard Ramirez guy myself is he the guy
who killed people at the seesaw
uh he used to go to the Cecil yeah that
guy's a [ __ ] that guy killed kids and
like I know he's a horrible [ __ ]
yeah that oh yeah that dude's crazy but
as far as stories go which is what I'm
which I like about the True Crime
um
Golden State killer is the [ __ ] King
for me I love his ass
uh but anyway he's it oh did he die or
is he in jail I don't remember
yeah it turns out he was an ex-cop I'm
telling you it was such a crazy story
um so anyway there's that tomorrow we're
looking forward to that it'll be fun and
um
there that is you know it's Gabe's uh
was Gabe's birthday party and actually
nobody went
damn
nobody went we were all gonna go and
then nobody I wasn't I never committed
that's horrible guys I never said I was
going frankly I'm not talking about I
didn't say anything I didn't say Dan I
blame Zach even though I don't want to
catch any heat that's what I'm saying I
blame Zach yes it is actually it was a
domino effect Zach isn't here by the way
I said if if people went I would go I
was on that boat too I was actually one
of the first to say I want to go we
should all go yeah so what happened how
did it all fall apart Zach fake friends
people are saying so Zach doesn't go and
it all falls apart Gabe did say that
Zach was the most important one by the
way Zach's gone he was sick today I hope
he's feeling better but we have Flocka
Flocka on this album there it is
making a mockery of Zach's art back
there because all you do is flakka and
people love it Zach deleted all the
flockas off the computer are you serious
he hates that you get laughs with that
because he worked so hard back there I
think it's the perfect mix because
obviously I can't do what he does he's
the goat so it's just my own thing on
the side and he has everything else I
just got the one sound bite Flocka
Flocka I mean it says a lot yeah yeah so
what happened what how did this all fall
apart
uh Zach had uh tickets to a trip A Pink
Floyd tribute band and then when Zach
couldn't go and it just kind of always
it is 95. other people had plans too so
it's like
well he got tickets to see Pink Floyd
Pink Floyd tribute band yeah so it
wasn't any of the it wasn't having
anything to do with like the actual it
was a champion I mean David Gilmore may
have been there I'm not sure but yeah no
it's it's a tribute band I heard there
was a Pink Floyd tribute band at Gabe's
house
really yeah it's just a deal with the
guitar oh well then you can do a tribute
to being Floyd I love them that's
disappointing then
yeah I don't know we were I was kind of
just joking but I I don't know I mean
ever since Zach sold out the Troubadour
I feel like he's changed yeah
[ __ ] I think you know what I
mean he's he I think he big timed White
Club game
a little bit all of a sudden you saw the
Troubadour and you're and then you're
flaking on your best friends like Gabe
how are we gonna make it up the game
that's my question we gotta we gotta do
something we gotta incorporate in one of
the holiday specials
we should give them the world we got to
give them Zach's Rolex the world yeah he
deserves it he deserves it if I had the
world
yeah we deserves fried chicken meat
[ __ ]
um yeah I needed to know what
Shenanigans went down there with
strippers and he was going to eat a
stripper out or something I don't know
well I mean that was just you okay
he never said that
well we'll we'll maybe we'll get him on
the live show for sure
yeah
and we'll make Zack it on his knees and
grovel for forgiveness at the live show
all right well anyway I hope you're
feeling better Zach we love you buddy
and uh
well we got you covered though in the
meantime amen oh I was gonna say ask for
a decent amen vodka too though we
couldn't get a Flocka yeah there it is
yeah thank you also thank you guys
remind us 200 to DPI all right
it was not me you got it you can't do
that [ __ ] Bro 1 600. well I had to turn
it back it was as many voices in my head
okay I can't have the DPA guy 8200 DPI
because it's overwhelming and the voices
that are already in my head it's too
much I can't do a show 800 DPI mother
that's the last time I had to turn it
down it was too high
yeah Black Friday sale going until the
end of the week or Friday I don't
remember
but actually actually I wanted to give a
shout out to this shirt I'm wearing now
um I made this shirt and I think it went
under the radar
God damn it I'll just search for it
there's so much stuff on the website
right now I'm literally what's on the
website with the stuff on it
um [ __ ] it
oh
yeah so this is the shirt my favorite
things and I I painstakingly picked
these out
cupcake
apparent weed paraphernalia that I don't
smoke by the way but I just thought it
was funny yeah why Coke why are you
lying I know I'm fronting you don't have
to lie to kick it
uh whiskey I don't drink either Donuts
video games mushrooms this is someone
doing a line
french fries beer
pills more mushrooms this is beer and
cigarettes and also I guess this is
supposed to be like corn and burrito
pure debauchery my favorite things and
let's be real they are we like we like
these things these are our favorite
things we don't like work and lame
stupid [ __ ] we want to get high and we
want to jerk off and we want to I don't
know some other stuff so these are my
favorite things and when I was making it
I was listening to John Coltrane foreign
thank you BD for the 20 gifted uh subies
thank you thank you all right thanks
guys honeyfresh.com and it's on sale all
right no it's not on sale my bad it's
full price because it came out last
month
all right enough
that's enough
yo
um Ian you Ian got a brand new car
you're coming out brother
give it up Ian finally and you know Ian
you've had notoriously probably the
worst luck of anyone I know with a car I
remember when you first started working
for us you bought the old uh [ __ ] the GT
with the wood panels baby PT Cruiser
baby that thing was sweet boy
yep
it was nice horrible
um it's an embarrassing thing to drive
around in but it's a good like starter
car at the time they lasted about three
months until it fell apart yeah Ian
drove all the way up to Marin County
right
that was for the second one I had to go
pick that up like eight hours away and
then that one also fell apart oh my God
so how much did you end up spending on
like totally uh broken cars before you
got a new one uh I don't know the total
but you know it was
I probably went too cheap with it I went
a little higher this time so hopefully
it lasts yes so um
so what'd you get right it's it's a
Honda Civic it's a news brand new though
new car dude new car that's a big deal
it is a big deal it's my first new car
ever I've never it's nice right yeah
it's crazy you know it's it does all
this stuff I didn't know was possible
with cars yeah dude when you get a new
card they really deck them out even with
like the you said it was an accord uh
Civic oh they make them nice right
yeah I mean it has all the like Lane
adjusting and like
um the uh
adaptive cruise control and all this
stuff that's cool does it have like the
backup Cam and the sensors and stuff
yeah it has like
different backup cams like there's a
downward one yes all that stuff wait you
can you can live switch your backup cam
yes you have a lot of experience with
that it's doing that it's so nice
congrats bro you're gonna be great
you're I mean it's gonna break down in
five months it's just Dustin yeah but
enjoy it until then for sure I will
thank you Honda gang and why did you
pick that car by the way of all the
options I'm like it's funny because I
was never really a car guy and then
looking for a car because the market is
so bad right now right I just I looked
into so many cars and that one's just a
good of like looking kind of nice but
also reliable and affordable it was like
the perfect it's a great car yeah Civics
are fantastic notoriously uh last a long
time which is yeah
so you got this yeah I mean you hear the
Civic the Accord and like the Camry and
[ __ ] like that you know what I mean
those are like the good old cars you get
and like the Toyota Corolla I would the
Corolla right right right right right
right
there it is man if you're not here [ __ ]
I always keep forgetting
I was like damn what do you think about
your man
she's like and you know obviously I was
bumming rides off of her for a bit there
so um
now I get to return the favor congrats
and actually I remember you told me you
had to go down to Lake Tahoe so that to
actually get the privilege of being smrp
right yeah that that was one of the
reasons we couldn't go to Gabe's because
uh we had a flight
uh the next morning so I I flew to Reno
to buy it uh Reno [ __ ] that was
literally the only place I pulled
probably 40 dealerships and they all
wanted to mark it up about like nine
thousand dollars yeah that's like
standard across the board and I would
say I would be like I'm looking to get
MSRP and one of the guys that straight
up laughed and he was like I'm telling
you right now dude that's a pipe dream
you will never get that and uh Reno that
was the only place that could do it so
so you said hey I'm trying to get MSRP
what'd they say and when you called a
Reno they were like yeah we can do that
and I was like oh [ __ ] shocked yeah so
because they're like nobody's here we're
not selling [ __ ] like really yeah like
nobody well that's that's what was it
Ian like I guess it was like a couple
months ago now
we were talking about it and kind of
came to the conclusion you got to get
far away from Los Angeles yeah any hope
of getting a car for a price like that
yeah it's it's pretty rough
um so I got on Saturday and then I
uh stayed the night and then I drove
back yesterday so it was about nice I
was that drive from like sweet boy get
that AC going yeah I play like some
relaxing like yes like Spanish guitars
oh desert and I set the Moon
hmm people are saying that car is going
to last you 300 000 miles bro you're in
that would be that would be the drink be
nice
congrats dude thank you thank you proud
of you man Happy Pharrell MSRP what a
Dream by the way those car salesmen who
are reaming everyone are going to be
[ __ ] back on the back foot here soon
I'm telling you dude those prices are
gonna be going down demand's going down
and those guys can all get [ __ ] bro
and [ __ ] BMW by the way too
we did get the car I wanted by the way
from a different dealer wait what you do
we went to a different dealer
it's not the same card they said we have
one but you got it yeah well you know
what happened Alina helped me with all
this we found the same car from a
different dealer it's not exactly
exact differences
um but yeah same car and it's gonna be
ready I believe in time yes nice and by
the way it's in LA or it's like in it's
it's one of the dealers in L.A uh and
it's like they're such [ __ ] dude
they're just like and the markup was
less too right Lena yeah they were um
they were good with that yeah it wasn't
even like a huge markup and the guy's
like dude there's only the guy who
[ __ ] us was like there's only two of
these in La dude uh you're just you're
not gonna be able to get another one did
he say that to you Lena
yeah yeah but in a very rude right way
yeah and I called like the dealer next
door and they're like yeah we can do it
[ __ ]
[ __ ] them
anyway BML that's right
well there it is car good car news uh
from the front uh for everybody we love
that
um
also huge news before we get into the
main stories of the day
we had such a good time talking about
Jay Leno's body getting charred and
[ __ ] deep fried and putting in a
hyperbaric chamber I mean it was just a
good time I'm not even gonna lie about
it I'm sorry jay I'm sorry that happened
to you
but that's the hardest I've left in a
long time it was fainted all right and
I'll tell you why
it was this photo here and I like to
relive this
if possible Jay Leno's Wiki feet
this guy
on his Wiki feed page has the pictures
of him in that hyperbaric chamber on
Wiki feet I mean that's so funny as [ __ ]
I don't give a [ __ ] that's one of the
funniest things you'll ever see in your
life did
why is it putting it there
what what is this [ __ ]
okay there I mean this [ __ ] tits on a
[ __ ]
sorry
I'm not doing what I want yeah so here's
Jay Leno of course I thought was looking
pretty good
All Things Considered real good
he's like don't show my face
yeah but actually uh shout out to Jay
Leno he showed his face and he's looking
good like I said
so let's take a look Jay Leno after
getting his face
scorched by A Thousand Suns
mother of Christ dude these social media
nothing's working for me
I thought am I not logged into Twitter
here you can you can dismiss that just
hit a Escape
are you sure about that I don't believe
so
Elon Musk changed it
no it's always it's always been you have
to log in
okay well
all right well I need someone to send me
this [ __ ] photo because apparently I
can't even open a goddamn Tweet now
yeah so let's take a look get in there
real nice not the chin damn not the chin
oh shut up uh Jordan oh his hand gut
his hand is the worst part his hand he
damn his hand look be looking like Mitch
McConnell hand
wow yeah
that's unironically true
it's not that I mean he you know I've
seen worse not many but
he doesn't look that bad right he's fine
he looks great yeah it's Battle Scars
you know I mean
how old is Jay Leno anyway it's like he
already you know he already lived his
life you're gonna get burned sometime in
your life now it's the time 72. 72 Now's
the Time to get face Burns you know what
I mean
like of all the times in your life this
is this is the best
so I'm happy for him
that hyperbaric chamber really worked
out in his favor you can tell
in fact I heard he got one for a bed he
could be sleeping in hyperbaric chambers
from now on
all right thank you Jay Leno there's one
other update about Jay
the link oh yeah yeah of course of
course and during the wiki feat
um
Saga
we did send his feet pictures from
wikiFeet to c-man our resident foot
expert
and to get them raided
and he did respond
um very he did happy to announce now
again just to remind you the pictures he
rated was this the one you sent him
uh yes so c-man without missing a beat
or even asking what is this
right
dude why can't I zoom why why is because
you're zooming before the pop-out comes
out and then you're you're over zoomed
no it's not here it is here's the pop
out right
how am I over jimming I'm literally just
zooming
I haven't zoomed okay are you happy okay
I guess so now we're gonna Zoom
it's just not right Wiki feet it's just
not you're right
yeah so it's a bad website they suck
it's [ __ ] sucks dude everything's
falling apart since they've removed the
leaderboard yeah
it's just been falling apart okay here
it is all right so here's the feet picks
that c-man rated uh he did not ask for
contacts you asked what is this right
then
uh uh he did ask who it was I mean
you'll see in the message so here's the
here's the picture we sent him and here
is he-man's response uh he says we said
hey C man you're probably busy but if
you have a moment can you tell us what
you think about these feet
here's the image he saw just this
it's obviously someone on the hospital
uh who are they feed our knife
it fell from there huh yeah
I mean they do look nice who was that
the whole combo
that was it that was it did you respond
yeah I told him it's Jay Leno
dude you can tell those are nice with he
was super excited about that yeah all
the exclamation marks really got me
because usually he's he's quite passive
I think for the most part on feet am I
right or wrong like he was excited about
Jay Leno's feet so there you have it
congratulations buddy
your face got [ __ ] charred but your
feet are undamaged and we love that yes
at 72 there's no there's no better time
to get a burn on your face I'm just
saying
the only time better than 72 73.
thank you
yeah
I feel so quiet here today without Zach
feels quiet
maybe because 1 600 DPI [ __ ] that
we need you back
what's his name
I want to know his name
the DPI guy
I can play just more random sound bites
I don't know if that would help that
won't help that's not good okay DPI
all right so let's do uh we gotta talk
about Twitter it's continues to be a rat
hole Elon unbanned Donald Trump Andrew
Tate and Jordan Peterson and Kanye who
quickly took to making anti-semitic
posts I love it it's crazy dude let me
just open this to tease you guys first
thing he goes shalom
okay Elon Musk liked it too that's crazy
the way I interpreted that you know as a
Jewish person it actually made me angry
because it's like
everyone knows he's been doing this
anti-semitic World Tour and for him to
come out and say shalom was like
yeah it's obvious he's like yeah [ __ ]
the Jews I didn't forget yeah now what
and Elon Musk like that for some reason
that's [ __ ] crazy dude what an
[ __ ]
I could literally say anti-semitic [ __ ]
and they can't drop me
by the way
um a b was a maybe you were at the Gap
that you like went out of business yeah
the Gap near our house completely closed
that was the one you kept walking by the
Gap and they had all the trash bags of
of Kanye stuff right yeah and then they
just shut that [ __ ] down he he must
have hurt that business so badly yeah
holy [ __ ]
yeah
there you go Elon Musk
I agrees
[ __ ] the Jews he says Elon Musk quote
unquote
and here is the Israeli uh is this real
just their Twitter account Israel yeah
what is this human I'd like to be
excluded from this narrative
Taylor Swift what's going on here
I don't know but it's morbid that's uh
something Taylor Swift said to uh
yo Israel's dropping Taylor Swift swift
references
that's a little weird
the evil doings of Israel the Shalom yes
it's really us
welcome to the state of Israel's
official Twitter account managed by the
Israeli mfa's digital diplomacy team so
they just have some Boomers managing
this [ __ ]
or I mean not Boomers some gen some
Zoomers some Zoomers yeah
probably
it's probably her let's be real
I don't know if she is okay well shout
out um okay Israel the state of Israel
loves uh Taylor Swift
okay you know what I'm missing is the
round of applause
after no that one's that one's too much
too much um clap those cheeks how about
this one
that one's too much excitement
you need like are you talking about like
the golf clap
well there's the golf clap
and then there's kind of like a general
Applause which does a lot for me okay
let me hear my ego let me go through
Zach's two programs and find it yeah I'm
gonna need that one hey let me show you
some of his labels
game show music H3 season 2 H3 season 2
part 2 H treason H3 season three I like
it H3 season three part two will play
one
all right here we go
what was that one labeled as
better it hits me than you
what I guess it's the name of it I think
you hit music at the same time by
accident oh let's see well better it
hits me if it hits you oh that would be
Mobility Mary of course yeah rest in
peace uh ghost of Mobility Mary queen
forever rest in power I miss her okay
all right all right
Twitter's a [ __ ] Rat Hole issue
podcast is a rat hole that's right so
yeah we're going to talk about Twitter
some dude on critical's podcast
pissed me off dude I swear to God and
then the World Cup in Qatar is a total
train wreck it's actually insane
um How does the so gross what's going on
there I saw they were putting up public
signs like no Jewish prayer allowed
what I didn't see that one for food and
no Jewish prayers allowed swear to God
swear to God they forbid kosher food
like why
[Music]
um let's just go through it all right
thank you
peace and love so Twitter's a rat hole
okay yeah Elon did the thing he unbanned
Trump
now this by the way
is so disingenuous he knew it was gonna
pass in fact elon's such a [ __ ]
hypocrite he talks about
embodying being the ultimate problem
with Twitter yet he goddamn well knows
this was entirely decided by Bots
50 million
you know 1 million votes and 15 million
Bots voted
so of course I voted yes because like
well if it's a rat hole let's just go
all the way you know what I mean
and then it unchecked my vote because
I'm banned
so there's that
um snuck says I would like to donate
this to Ian fun uh love all you but Ian
is goaded okay
there is no Ian fund oh there's no one
sorry Dan stop yeah that doesn't exist
that's not a uh fund so I will
appropriate that for myself thank you
I'm just kidding
minus taxes and YouTube I mean YouTube's
got full fees labor I have an hourly
rate I have to send it to him through
Zell right our late is very high yeah
I make a lot of money no he's pretty
expensive time is valuable yeah yeah
big time
yeah you probably have a couple bucks
left over by the time it gets you know
not a problem
um
so what do you what did you guys think
it was like obviously going to pass
right yeah I mean no [ __ ] yeah it's like
I don't know
but it's all kind of moot because
Trump said nah I'm good
nah I'm good fam
okay guys I got a problem here what's up
[Music]
how am I supposed to get to this item in
the document when I don't have access
access people it's a live show
uh
uh I don't know I don't know why you
don't have access because you're logged
into podcast account [ __ ]
something weird happened there because
it's Monday not Wednesday
yeah I mean who made it okay Jesus
Christ I see that it's shared with you I
don't know that seems like the best
access it seems like a bug
seriously here I'm missing a request
okay hey let me set a request guys hold
on one sec
no big deal okay this is uh not
anybody's fault Google is uh having an
issue here because it's on our shared
Drive everybody has access to it I don't
know why keep in mind
keep in mind Google is a small Indie
company yeah so yeah
hold the phone
hold the phone
yeah I'm literally I'm looking at the
permissions right now well just just
change it to anyone who has the link and
look at it okay yo you're in trouble
try now yeah now I can see it
so yeah here's Trump says he's not
coming back but
do you believe him I don't know I
already invested in true social exactly
it's his whole it's his whole thing
yeah I don't there's a chance he might
not come back it's hard though to say
because it's not the same like whenever
that [ __ ] tweeted I saw that
everybody saw it on Twitter he has four
million people on true social and 85
million on Twitter so
yeah I don't know it's more of a reach
for sure the power he's he'll come back
probably I don't know I don't know
because he he owns a social media
company now and Twitter is clearly in
trouble and Elon needs Trump more than
Trump needs Elon at this point you know
what I mean that's actually true he's
trying really desperately to bait him
into getting back onto the platform
because he needs that engagement he
needs and he needs to Pander to that
crowd because the woke moralists are all
leaving in droves and they're losing
advertisers every day and Trump brings a
lot of traffic to the website
um so if Trump's smart which is
questionable uh I don't think he has a
good motivation to come back if Twitter
goes under truth social be well
positioned to become like
at least for the at least for the right
which has become their yeah but it's
also I also wonder like if Trump did
come back that would probably offer more
obstacles to Bringing sponsors back no
uh yeah but I you have to think at this
point Elon I mean he's doubled down on
this I I think
he's got to just be thinking either
we'll get the traffic so high that even
that the advertisers won't be able to
say no because it's just too juicy of a
platform to advertise on right or he
thinks he's going to make up that
Revenue by
charging the users with [ __ ] like the
check mark stuff yeah and otherwise
right which isn't going he's going well
either Elon is super invested in this
idiotic idea that Twitter is the world's
Public Square and so I guess yeah the
Public Square that I own privately
exactly I love that nobody nobody seems
to uh remember that part
um and so but okay Trump says you're not
coming back but he unbanned him
so there that is and now this I found
was interesting this one is kind of
[ __ ]
tells the whole story now Sam Harris
says is it time to let Alex Jones back
on Twitter Elon Musk if not why not
because I mean Fair Point right he says
everybody's I'm unbanning everybody uh
ultimate Free Speech platform Battle of
ideas whatever the [ __ ]
okay and so he responds
I don't know what the [ __ ] I guess is a
Bible quote I don't know bro it's a
weirdo suffer a little trip and forbid
them not to come on to me
for such is the Kingdom of Heaven it's
not funny you really want to post about
little children coming on to you bro and
being heavily it's a little
inappropriate isn't it
typically long
that's disgusting man
uh what is Twitter owned by the Catholic
church or Elon Musk get it restrained
Jack
yeah so then this is when he really
[ __ ] up in my opinion he says
first of all uh I need to put in
parentheses emotional uh
my firstborn child died in my arms
I felt his last heartbeat I have no
mercy for anyone who would use the
deaths of children for gain politics or
fame now what's funny
is that I of course believe I agree
totally with uh Elon Musk
that Alex Jones shouldn't be brought
back but I'm not a free speech
absolutist and
what's so crazy about this is that he is
the sole decider
of who stays on and who stays off don't
you see how [ __ ] insane that is like
there's no policy here it's just Elon
says I don't like Alex Jones so he stays
off
right like yeah I mean essentially it's
such a blaring hypocrisy
that it's actually quite incredible that
he even wrote that down I get it I agree
with him right
but everyone says I'm a [ __ ] psycho
cancel culture freak but he's the Free
Speech Warrior so what which is it
I don't get it yeah I mean
we've always known all that rhetoric as
[ __ ] and yeah I mean it is
interesting to see it just kind of get
exposed for what it is and you know we
called This months ago it's inevitable I
mean if you look at the replies and
quote tweets to that uh I mean I can
pretty much guarantee you it's a bunch
of people that normally like Elon
they're like this is the worst take you
know
oh yes they're turning and I mean this
is just dumb I think by any metric it's
entirely scary that Elon musk's stated
purpose is to have Twitter be this free
and open Public Square
but also openly admitting that he is the
solar decider of who's allowed there
based on if he likes them or not
like come on what the [ __ ] and the
conservatives are just loving it like
you should see how Jordan Peterson is
like literally kissing the [ __ ] floor
he walks on bro they just they have no
[ __ ] ethics they have no principles
at all
um I am glad Jordan's back though I
gotta say just just for comedy sake well
you know what you know it's ironic is
that since Jordan Peterson's back
Twitter is like um
Twitter says new Xanax bro it put and
it's gonna damage his brain yeah oh it
already has he's poisoned as [ __ ] he
he's so brain dead on Twitter a fact the
first like hour that his band got lifted
he tweeted like 40 times and that's not
an exaggeration like no it was like and
and it's like at first he goes thank you
uh memes and then he's angry at pissed
at the culture War stuff
um that troying Peterson should be
thanking God he was banned off Twitter
yeah I mean it's like deaf noodles
remember how he got unbanned on Twitter
and then like all hell broke loose for
him oh absolutely
oh you do remember that okay
so
um
by the way do you guys have I wanted to
get an album of people responding
did you guys grab that or not
I don't believe so now
all righty
so I wanted to look at the Republican um
response to this because people are
definitely turning on them
to The Alex Jones thing yeah
or I need I guess I can't really because
I'm not logged into Twitter
you're banned
all right well it's all right we'll move
on and then so yeah Kanye is back on
Twitter which I already showed
and anti-Semitism is just like a fun
silly goofy thing now I guess that even
Elon Musk likes 500 000 uh likes and
that's fun and exciting isn't it
um
am I is it possible to read this any
other way because he's like a black
Israelite where like he's like no I'm
the is there any way to read this where
it's not just like super inflammatory
anti-semitism
I'm just I'm trying to give him the
benefit of the doubt if possible
no no not really right no because when I
responded to that
um when I saw that I actually got like
tangibly angry
ah brother
I didn't even know he was oh yeah he was
banned because he tweeted out some [ __ ]
like what did he tweet he got banned for
some really crazy [ __ ]
is that he was going Defcon 3 on the
Jews oh yeah yeah the Defcon 3. you
bring him back he's going to come three
and all Jewish people
and then you brought him back and he
gets he hits him with the shalom
okay
Twitter's interest turning into an
interesting place man
um elim Jordan Peterson is back this is
my favorite super villain by the way he
was never banned all he had to do was
erase a tweet [ __ ] drama queen [ __ ]
thanks Ellen he called him Ellen
idiot such a dumbass you [ __ ] you
you're big you're big ultimate tweet
that you're back you called as him Ellen
you [ __ ]
thank you the idiot well wait a minute
because it wasn't it he's probably
oh it's related to the Elliot page thing
oh [ __ ] I think it's because that's
Elliot's uh dead name I think it's
because he uh he misspelled it though
Ellen's with two o's Elon misspelled
Jordan as Jordan so he's he's joking
back at him
ah wow we really dug into yeah we really
yeah there's layers there's layers to
the humor there's layers
there you gotta think if you really want
to know what Ellen means you have to
look at how many L's are in it you have
to look at the quote tweet
uh really thank you sir probably best to
reinstate Trump too let him do what he
needs to do and let the people decide
right out in the open where such things
should be decided I laughed when I saw
this this was before Elon Musk unbanned
Trump and it's like shut the [ __ ] up
idiot like shut up
like his opinion he really thinks his
opinion is so [ __ ] important he had
to tell Elon you need to unban Trump too
by the way
it's so funny this whole thing is such a
[ __ ] show man
and then now here's Jordan by the way
this was let's see let's check the time
stamps um
I mean this was directly after that
tweet of him being unbanned
uh Elon says
new Twitter policy of freedom speech not
freedom of reach okay
he says negative hates which will be Max
D boosted that's when we're like he's
just gonna Shadow ban people who are
mean Jordan said don't allow the
anonymous troll demons to post with real
verified people
put them in their own hell along with
others like them lol LOLs bro bruh hyper
users are narcissistic Machiavellian
Psychopathic and sadistic really
yo I don't know if you all ever said
bruh but chances are you need to be
institutionalized
anyone who said bruh you're
Machiavellian as [ __ ] bruh
he's crazy
and like and and morally his his ethical
line is like there's no sense to it he
on one he literally just a minute ago
was like free speech for everybody let
Donald Trump back and he says let the
demon have trolls rotten to hell
who's used the word lulls and bro
this man
is rotting from the inside out yeah and
this is your hero
unfucking real it's unreal and I'm the
guy I'm the I'm the guy who apparently
hates Free Speech really is crazy world
we live in
[ __ ] me for making a joke you know what
I mean and getting suspended
Kanye West is like I don't think the
Holocaust was dope and we should do it
again and they're like let's bring him
back
Defcon 3.
on all Jewish people
so there it is uh Jordan Peterson is
doing well mentally and uh we're gonna
be seeing all kinds of great takes and
tweets from him so we look forward to
that Happy Thanksgiving Dr Jordan
Peterson I'm sure
you guys were having a lovely Time
Around the Christmas table with uh your
uh daughter's ex-boyfriend Andrew Tate
[ __ ] you
and of course there'll be no apple cider
thank you thank you peace and love Bruh
Bruh oh send him back wow
you just got oh Jordan 4K Jordan go to
hell demon Jordan LOL wow
dude he's so [ __ ] demented bro
and then there's um elon's been tweeting
lots of memes and copium
let's see
I mean so far though I have to say that
Twitter hasn't gone offline or anything
which is what a lot of people were kind
of anticipating I mean it can still
happen
like I saw another report
um
uh just last night the Twitter head of
French operation said he was quitting
the social media platform whose new
owner Elon Musk recently fired top
executives
and for Steep job cuts at the company
it's over
he tweeted on Sunday thanking his team
in France which led him for several
years so like [ __ ] is still hitting the
fan
and what's really interesting when you
have like a Multinational Global uh
social media company like Twitter
again they operate in so many different
countries in Europe specifically the
privacy and consumer
laws aren't really insane and
complicated and so
um you need a lot of people to be
managing that appropriately and I just
don't see how he's not going to get sued
into Oblivion from all these privacy or
find yeah fine sued uh turned off in
countries
[Music]
okay
um
the main Broski 10 bucks bringing back
my go-to name for him Jordan benzos
Peterson yeah that's good
Peterson uh Elon Musk has been tweeting
fan fanaticism is always a function of
repressed doubt
okay
hope all judge you Hall monitors today
on other platforms please I'm begging
you
bro are you talking about Jordan
Peterson
he just literally said anyone who says
abroad needs to broaden hell for all
eternity right
bruh also you said Alex Jones isn't
allowed back on the platform because you
don't like him personally you don't like
him he just did something that offended
him yeah I don't like it so there's no
policy don't you see the problem guys
Twitter is fun okay
our love seems like he's having a great
time yeah he's been having a great week
he's posting through the pain big time
no he's having no he's he's having fun
he's having a good time a lot of his
friends are here just out of frame
our love will never die apparently CBS
News quit Twitter I don't know I don't
know what that was about
um and it was about him losing more
average they suspended all advertising
Oh I thought they said they'd stop
tweeting
uh no they suspended all advertising
they may have done that too CBS News
just CBS in general they do I mean the
the corporation the media conglomerate
is pulling their ad done can you fact
check that I'm just with like a article
I want to see the
because it that the strategy of
attacking sponsors that pull out is
probably not going to play well for him
even I am dumb enough not to do that I
think I've never done that
and lead us not into temp Temptation
Donald Trump yeah he's been posting lots
of stuff like this Twitter is alive he
retweeted his own tweet so isn't that
nice
why would he do that what an idiot
dumbass stupid [ __ ] he did
um he also liked a tweet that called him
an innervator and compared him to look
at that he liked this sweet oh I'm sorry
but look at this love or hate Elon Musk
but there's very few people in history
who are true innovators Tesla Benjamin
Franklin Henry Ford Alexander Alexander
Graham Bell Thomas Edison whether you
like him or not Elon Musk is one of
those rare innovators
he liked that
it's so weird like that but also is he
he's not really an innovator of anything
is he I mean he just bought company uh
cat turd 2 says so right so
I mean Tesla is an inventor Benjamin
Franklin's an inventor Henry Ford
I mean I know he's credited with like
the with like consumable cars space
travel
space travel I mean he invent spaces but
he didn't he innovate uh different
aspects that's true that's true in the
same way Henry Ford made like cars right
accessible I guess he made space travel
more accessible
[Music]
I guess Dan I mean we could we can give
that up to him right Dan's hesitant I
think he gets okay I mean what about
innovating naming his children
dad
he didn't definitely got him yeah yeah
no nobody has named his child next well
yeah but at the same time nobody I mean
uh being an absent parent is uh iconic
americanism it's by the sound of what
our discussions yesterday
so or I mean he's an immigrant living
the American dream you know
Thomas Edison okay all right maybe he's
one of those rare inventors but it's I
don't but it's weird to like that tweet
right yes it's extremely weird it's a
little [ __ ] narcissistic and by the
way are you really cruising Twitter that
much to get to that comment with 150
likes
that dude
aren't you supposed to be working
he's the hardest working CEO in the biz
baby just on Twitter it's just like a
hundred percent of the day
it's wild
it's so wild
uh I did a thing uh did a funny tweet we
liked this or he said since no one's
moderating Twitter right now I'm
currently making math
and uh that's pretty good
I hope it's true actually
I certainly could be
so there it is congratulations to him
also you you were right about the CBs
thing they're they're just not using the
platform anymore from what I'm saying
yeah but so I guess they started posting
again which is pretty embarrassing for
them honestly yeah I'm reading articles
as they restarted using it after
stopping what idiots they pulled a
quartering they pulled a quartering dude
I'm quitting Twitter why would they do
that what's stupid embarrassing
everybody everybody that says they're
quitting Twitter does that but they
literally lasted a day yep that sounds
like Jordan Peterson in the quarter
because then Jordan do that too yeah he
does that it was like an hour later I'm
avoiding Twitter it's a rat hole
[ __ ] trans people by the way I had to
come back to say that
yeah that's kind of the uh current state
of Twitter so we'll see but I I gotta
say I don't know what to expect because
on one hand it's still up you know well
the website's functional but I mean I
think the
I think the bigger uh thing to keep an
eye on is just the business model
um there's all this stuff apparently
they from the loans that he took in
order to buy it uh the interest is about
a billion dollars uh
and there for what year
yeah I think so yeah I mean 44 billion
is kind of a lot of money
right
it's quite a large loan to take yeah I
hope it's not per month no it's per year
and um
and yeah I mean they're losing
advertisers like crazy and Eight dollar
a month Twitter blue subscribers uh is
gonna be tough to make up well it's not
even live did they bring it back yet not
yet yeah it's supposedly they're
relaunching it again yeah
there it is well good luck Elon you're
gonna [ __ ] need it in the words of
Kim start you got that one good luck
Elon and it's so close to Ethan you
could edit that and make it
um Good Luck Ethan Elon
you're gonna [ __ ] need it
good luckie Ethan because you're gonna
[ __ ] eat long
we can find a way it's easy you just
overdo type it good luck with all of
that
anyway so there's that
um
all right so everyone wants to know what
happened critical critical didn't do
anything I like crit it was one of the
people on the show that pissed me off
because
this is the type of [ __ ] that I'm seeing
all the [ __ ] time now
um it's like the alpha it reminds me of
when keemstar started this crazy
uh
uh theory that I ripped off the fupa
punch the football fun [ __ ] right
I [ __ ] up and so somehow this whole
narrative I don't know if it's from like
Tick Tock or all these commentary
YouTubers who like take the most
ungenerous worst worst possible
interpretation from everything I do
because you know obviously I got banned
on Twitter and somehow people have
warped this into like I'm a hypocrite
because I'm complaining that I was
banned and I don't believe in free
speech and this guy takes it even
further in a funny way he goes it's
identity theft Ethan was committing
identity theft I says [ __ ] hypocrite
I says are you [ __ ] serious dude
all right let's watch it no hate to a
crit there
I'm also gonna roast uh ordinary gamer a
little bit here too because this guy
[ __ ] up already once and was like dude
you got to start learning your lesson
man there's some straight up weirdos
so let's just watch them and I'll break
this down for you no hate to crit
obviously uh I'm just click betting his
face okay
so don't kill me okay fine leave me
alone
another guy that got um bands was can
you turn it up
good just from him saying that they took
so much psychic damage they're like stun
locked in front of their [ __ ] phones
trying to come up with how am I gonna
own them another guy that got um bands
was at least I'm Ethan Klein yeah he got
chocolate slime million followers again
he went on his account and basically
Twitter hi I'm Elon and I'm a pedophile
I love Jeffrey Epstein and his uh little
babies that I used to [ __ ] or whatever
yeah so how about you show the [ __ ]
tweet if you're gonna come out here and
say you know make a point about how I
got banned show the [ __ ] tweet it's
obviously a joke it was actually going
viral on on Twitter because people
thought it was [ __ ] funny and when
you say it like that it sounds dumb
right but it wasn't dumb it was like a
[ __ ] joke with a purpose and so
um like what the [ __ ] are you even
saying dude pull up that tweet let me
read it like because I feel like
everywhere in the world people take
everything I do to the worst possible
interpretation it was so obviously a
joke with a purpose
and listen he he goes on listen he got
bands I'm like here's the two things
you're both Hypocrites Elon Musk should
be able to take a joke he's being a big
baby but also you're a hypocrite isn't
this what you said should happen when
somebody improves again this is like
this crazy hypothetical words like oh
Ethan's a hypocrite because
he's saying didn't you say this is what
should happen if someone impersonates
someone I don't give a [ __ ] about in
person no that's like your number one
Crusade dude you're talking about it on
the show all the time about how
impersonation is the number one man what
the [ __ ] is he talking about just to
give him the benefit of the doubt
because he's very he's operating on very
little uh uh uh uh Community computing
power here so let's just say I give him
the benefit of the doubt and he says
um what everyone else is saying which is
at least more coherent is that Ethan's
Pro Banning people on Twitter
yes so that would make more sense yes so
let's just I'm gonna give you the
benefit of the doubt because what you
said makes no [ __ ] sense right so he
says Ethan is pro getting people banned
on Twitter yet he got himself banned
what a hypocrite what's the hypocrisy I
did it on purpose knowing I was going to
get banned
um I never I don't complain about it I
don't say oh I did was banned undeserved
I don't say bring me back it was a joke
with the [ __ ] point bro like show the
Tweet you stupid idiot bro does nobody
have a [ __ ] brain anymore like holy
[ __ ] here's the tweet
I switched my name to Elon Musk right
after he goes um
he the context he says uh yeah anyone
who impersonates will be permanently
banned unless they say it's a parody so
okay I'm gonna test this this [ __ ]
guy
is not telling the truth I'ma test it I
put parity in the account I mean
sometimes I gotta explain this to you
[ __ ] a parody in the description I even
do the goddamn banner I wrote parity
account he didn't clarify till a week
later that he said going forward unless
you have parity in the name you're going
to get permanently banned y'all like to
[ __ ] like oh my god dude
foreign
Kathy Griffin who got banned this same
night for doing
I was gonna say exactly the same thing
not exactly the same thing worse because
she didn't have parody yeah
right okay so this guy talking about you
those vulgar tidbits about the kids that
he made that literally
I didn't say that you [ __ ] not even
close here
here's what I said okay and so you know
if you're gonna frame this at least give
the whole at least prepare a little bit
and like give the whole context I said
even though Jeffrey Epstein committed
horrible crimes I do still miss him on
nights like this for his warmth and
camaraderie rest in peace old friend
where's [ __ ] kids
where is anything like that it's clearly
a [ __ ] joke a funny one by the way I
will say and stand behind and so like
what the [ __ ] dude
what are you talking about and this is
why everybody gets these wrong ideas
about what I did
why are people saying blow my nose my
sniffing I didn't think I was do you
have a bug head you have a buggy oh can
we get a boogie cam I can oh my God
you're a boogie cam I don't think so oh
no you look pretty clean I mean I'll
blow my nose it'll make me feel insecure
okay there you go is that the content
you came for
fantastic like this is why all over the
internet I'm seeing people
who are just like hating me more and
more and it's this crazy Echo chamber
where people like this [ __ ] guy hears
something somewhere else and
regurgitates it and I I don't know if he
ever even looked at my [ __ ] tweet
he's talking about [ __ ] kids
no dude it's all joke
the joke is again here let me explain it
to you dude he's enjoying a summer
evening it's trouble he just bought
Twitter he's going through hard times
and he's just missing his dear friend
Jeffrey Epstein who even though he was a
horrible guy he really does miss his
warmth and camaraderie you know if only
he was here on this evening it would be
a little bit easier to handle
is that not funny am I not comedy
personified
all right well take it too far maybe I
mean it's a decent tweet it's good it's
good it's good I don't know if it's
comedy personal I mean it is comedy
personified bucket wow I'm just kidding
but listen to this [ __ ] [ __ ]
continue okay it I don't want to be like
an Elon dick rider oh then Here Comes
muda By the way you know a good thing's
coming slam this [ __ ] oh no
no time listen I want to like Buddha I
want to like him he seems like an
affable guy but he does step in it oh a
lot so so mudahar
he made a video about me during like the
height of Ethan hate and he's friends
with keemstar for some ungod-known
reason and uh he made a video about how
I'm like the worst person on the
internet because I stole money from the
fupa fund and the CR like bro I he
literally one of his Central points was
that I donation shamed Jeff Bezos do you
like that
[ __ ] like that like people actually
rode for that okay anyway I went through
his video Point by point and eviscerated
him he erased the video and apologized
and we since we've since made up but
like
yeah generally he's he's fine I just
don't know bro you can't come and talk
about [ __ ] like this and not [ __ ]
even have this the slightest idea of
what you're talking about I'm just tired
of people lying about me on the internet
especially to this [ __ ] because this
could be coming like it was before does
he does does he lie about you well let's
watch yeah that's one he's wrong
basically Tweeter hi I'm Elon and I'm a
pedophile basic is that what I basically
tweeted you [ __ ] brain dead
imbecile
but that's just that's just [ __ ] up
honestly Epstein and his uh little
babies that I used to [ __ ] or whatever
right I can't get over what an insanely
bad faith misrepresentation of the of my
tweet that is
[ __ ] and nobody pulls it up okay you got
bands and look here's two things you're
both Hypocrites Elon Musk should be able
to take a joke he's being a big baby but
also you're a hypocrite isn't this what
you said should happen when somebody
improves you I just can't get over it's
like people started doing this they'll
put any [ __ ] thing they want on me
and just act like that's what it is I
don't know what people do why that's
like people buy that isn't Ethan always
been in favor of like heavy punitive uh
punishment for impersonating like
something I've never talked about and
don't care about at all
it's just so stupid I don't want to be
like an Elon dick rider but like if you
just say like ah you're a pedophile like
haha like that's not really a joke it's
like sure no that wouldn't be a joke
that wouldn't be a joke yeah good point
good thing you didn't who are you
talking about you talking about me
because it seems like you're talking
about me but it doesn't apply to me at
all
maybe somebody should actually pull up
the [ __ ] tweet
before having this idiotic conversation
stupid [ __ ]
keemstar careful no I back that's your
friend I know you know let's consider it
should happen
I don't want to be like an Elon dick
writer but like if you just say like ah
you're a pedophile like haha like that's
not really a joke it's like a straight
up defamatory how is that an Elon dick
right he was like [ __ ] shut up just hey
make a point don't be such a baby bro
just say listen Ethan's a [ __ ] idiot
because he called Elon Muska pedophile
which didn't happen by the way
bro
I hate to defend Elon here but Ethan
kind of is a [ __ ] loser for tweeting
out that Elon [ __ ] babies
just a paraphrase
on an idiot bro
you know well yeah that's the
distinction I was trying to make with
the other things too where they were
going on you know changing their name to
Elon Musk and making like telling people
to dump their stocks and saying hey go
vote for this candidate like okay wait
that's not a joke you're actually
impersonating someone now that's a joke
I mean it's still a joke it's super
funny if somebody believes
somebody's dumb enough what happened
y'all are so [ __ ] sensitive you're so
desperate to defend Elon Musk you
[ __ ] losers that guy would step on
your [ __ ] life and [ __ ] down your
grandma's throat to save money you
idiots how did billionaires and convince
all y'all to ride their dick so hard
dude you guys think it's a joke
it is funny it is a joke
right if you're dumb enough to take
stock advice from fake Elon Musk account
During the period where it's like a
total free-for-all from Twitter blue
it's all [ __ ] shitstorm You're Gonna
Go dump stock that's funny bro
that's funny I don't give a [ __ ]
it maybe you're dumb enough to be
persuaded by that maybe that's why
you're offended
okay this guy lost his ass on on
Dogecoin earlier he's like yo bro I
click one of those it looked like a real
Elon account
I just dropped my life savings a
Dogecoin from a fake Elon account
this is it this is fraud
God damn
it is a joke it's funny
listen he goes further he gets it even
dumber Elon musking yeah I thought
comedy was alive and well what happened
all of a sudden comedy's live and well
now we're sitting here talking about
this isn't funny this is illegal this
just deserves to be banned what happened
comedy I thought it was free I thought
it was free speech and it's not funny
impersonating people is that's not
really considered it's a comedy like
doing impressions Impressions aren't
really uh traditionally associated with
uh comedy it's it's way over the line
and I've always said that right
it's a well-known thing that I say
to be a joke it's like a straight up
defamatory statement yeah uh if you're
gonna say that I'm defaming Elon Musk
let's pull up the [ __ ] tweet is that
too much to ask after the last time you
[ __ ] lied and made a whole video
about and I body slammed your dumb ass
to the ground you had to delete the
video let's not do that again I don't
want to [ __ ] do that again bro talk
about the alligator
it's like you the more you hang out with
keemstar the more you'll believe any
dumb [ __ ] thing he says into your
brain dude stop you're smart you're nice
you know what I mean
stop it bro please embarrass you know
well yeah that's the distinction I was
trying to make with the other things too
where they were
oh there's a bonus Ian
yo when did he drop this
heart dropped this
August
uh deleting Twitter keeping the username
this app is Hell okay
oh so he's been off Twitter since August
that's what he says here right yeah I'm
wow I didn't
that must be an impersonation account I
see no it's I can see the tag it's right
it says ordinary gaming no I'm saying
since August uh all of those tweets from
him another parody account you know
what's funny it's not you don't you're
crazy you can just look at the tag and
then you find out who the person is
right yeah right that's kind of like
like right it's not that hard you just
look at their at TAG it's really kind of
like a pretty easy thing to figure out
you see here it says at H3 Productions
damn that's crazy that's crazy as [ __ ]
dude
crazy
going on you know changing their name to
Elon Musk and making like telling people
to dump their stocks and saying hey go
vote for this candidate like okay wait
that's not a joke you're actually
impersonating someone now that's called
identity
that's my favorite take I'm sorry bro
but you could just spread that level of
stupidity unchecked on this [ __ ] I have
to [ __ ] it I'm dying inside
identity theft is you're talking about a
joke on Twitter where the handle is
still the native one it's a Dwight
Schrute ass you can take right there
identity theft are you are you is a
crime
you know what identity theft is it's
like when you steal someone's Social
Security number open credit cards in
their name run up debt in their name
that's identity theft you dumb [ __ ] not
making jokes about Elon Musk for my
Twitter account you're dumb bro you're
literally struggling
I don't know what to say I mean what the
[ __ ]
oh Lord I'm sorry dude
[Music]
they might watch this and they say
Ethan's being a dick he's going too hard
looking for from my perspective
this guy is perpetuating the biggest
[ __ ] [ __ ] lies about me that I'm
seeing more and more on the internet and
it's not cool you want to talk about
fraud you want to talk about defamation
he's so worried about it how about you
look at what I actually said You [ __ ]
talk about hypocrisy you literally said
I tweeted out that Elon Musk wants to
[ __ ] kids with Jeffrey with Jeffrey
Epstein okay I think that Elon could get
them for defaming in there ow
yeah I didn't say it they did they those
are their words the identity theft
yo by the way we need to sound bite that
[ __ ] because I want to use that anytime
anyone does any identity theft
unfortunately there's somebody talking
over him as he says bro every time we
play a sound bite identity theft that's
not funny oh whenever he
what do we do
identity theft whenever you relay
someone else's story that's identity
theft yeah it's crazy
Scary World out there man whenever Zach
plays I'm coming
I'm coming hold on I'm coming yes so
this [ __ ] pissed me off and you know
what like I'm sorry but I feel Justified
like this [ __ ] [ __ ] sucks bro you're
just you're being a total idiot
and and you're
you're just dead wrong so you know the
best part is still yeah actually I gotta
telling people to dump their stocks and
saying hey go vote for this candidate
like okay wait that's not a joke you're
actually impersonating someone now
you're not no you're not you're not
impersonating somebody really you're not
actually and it's not identity theft
actually try to defraud people with this
dude you're so dumb
foreign
you're defrauding people with a goofy
tweet
where the ah is still your name you're a
[ __ ] hypocrite I'm sorry [ __ ] so fair
enough if you ban them again I feel like
Elon is a big baby but yeah but at the
same time like isn't this what you
wanted Ethan yeah like didn't you say
yeah get banned for this
that's what's annoying
get banned for impersonations
when did you ever say that
isn't this what you wanted
you're a hypocrite because this is what
you wanted I don't know what you're
talking about dude about it to me is
like they went in with the goal of
getting banned I guess and then they do
like a shocked Pikachu face when they do
get banned not at all I haven't heard
him say anything about it thank you
okay let's now keep on pretending like
they actually know anything about what I
actually did thank you Charlie the only
one with a [ __ ] brain cell
you're actually trying to defraud people
with this [ __ ] so fair enough if you ban
them again I feel like Elon is a big
baby but yeah but at the same time like
isn't this what you wanted Ethan yeah
like didn't you say yeah let's just get
banned for this
that's what's annoying about it to me is
like they went in with the goal of
getting banned I guess and then they do
like a shocked Pikachu face when they do
get banned is Ethan I haven't heard him
say anything about it thank you I think
of course you have any space
he has two accounts one of them
obviously is not as big as the other I
think he has like yeah he has one for
his podcast and one for the I guess the
parents company or something but yeah
I guess Elon isn't for free speech after
all right that's literally just like
kind of punctuating the joke I made
right and uh uh first of all I don't own
that account okay you don't know what
you're talking about dude you're how
you're gonna bring me the smoke and not
be ready uh Charlie's the king Charlie
takes the dub he's the legend uh hold it
down
oh man these friends should be sucking
your dick Charlie because they would be
[ __ ] dead broke somewhere they'd be
working like the most dead-end job not
there's anything wrong with it but I'm
just saying like nepotism is great man
these guys should be sucking your dick
every [ __ ] day that you put them on
this podcast and let them make a living
while having two operating brain cells
Charlie you're
good you're basically Mother Teresa you
are
you are the most benevolent man alive
and I thanking you on their behalf
because I don't think they thank you
enough Charlie
thanks Ethan for what you do for them
you know what I mean
yeah but that doesn't necessarily mean
he was shocked now that I'm thinking
about it thank you I don't think people
Advance people oh my God even people and
that like you don't put an account with
two point something million followers on
the line really
well maybe you don't [ __ ] I do and I
did guess what I don't really give a
[ __ ] either I just find the whole thing
pretty amusing
guess what bro I'm just badass like that
he just called and called me badass
didn't he he's like nobody will put that
online here I am baby so I went back and
and pulled our conversation like in real
time as it was happening oh interesting
so I said and brought receipts this is
from my perspective so if it is not in
the handle I'm pretty sure you're
getting bought this is at 7 24 the night
that you were tweeting all this he said
what the different Twitter handles like
to do they have a policy written out
somewhere and I said I don't think that
matters he's mad about it which ended up
being true good ban me that's Ethan
um
and then Sam said he's just tweeting the
policy as he creates it I said exactly
he's like Vader pray that I don't change
it any further and then Ela says
whatever Twitter sucks anyways if you do
get banned
uh he's gonna be like new rule I said
listen I'm not one to talk you out of it
I think it's epic to Suicide your
account exactly but don't be surprised
when it happened this was we talked
about this on the show where I was just
voicing like I'm pretty sure that's
what's gonna happen and then you said uh
just having fun with it I won't be Ian
of course the only doubter famous last
words
and then you said yeah I'm totally cool
to Suicide it I'm here for it and then I
gave you a salute and you said I won't
be upset is what I'm saying yeah there
you go we all knew I mean we knew it was
coming it was funny nobody would ever
suicide a Twitter account with 2.3
million views thank you bro I am that
badass I really am that [ __ ] cool
dude and I'm just kind of cool and
apathetic to a level that you didn't
even know was possible unlike your dumb
worrying ass how much Twitter account
how many Twitter follows does he have
he's all [ __ ] oh I got to keep up I
gotta keep my Twitter account
shut up dude you'll never be as cool as
me
does have a good hairline though
as much as I don't like him I have to
admit that
how old is he
there's a little receiving Kyle he's
probably young but there's a little
receding going on here just a touch but
overall good
you know
not after this it won't be yeah I'm
gonna take that I'm absorbing that [ __ ]
what's his age I need to know uh
chirosaurin
age uh 31. well according to
famousbirthdays.com okay so you'll never
know if these are accurate No that's a
strong hairline for 31. he's doing all
right I respect that but if you start
losing hair no it was me
it was me yeah how many Twitter
followers does he have
oh yeah no wonder you're so impressed
because because you have 34 a thousand
followers and I am a god with 1.3
million oh yeah yeah you have zero
followers yeah I had 2.3 million but I'm
like a [ __ ] god to you dude
somebody chat said Kaya said something
like Hassan looks like an r wordist on
stream geez that sounds defamatory
oh but at the same time he's [ __ ]
posting about Jordan Peterson which I do
like well he said in the thing he
doesn't really care for Elon I I didn't
get the impression that he was really
taking elon's side it was more about
just finding any reason to bash on you
that's the thing it's like I don't know
why everyone is so determined to hate me
it's like everybody has to find a
[ __ ] reason to hate me and to see
everything in the worst possible way
it's like why you do what like what's
wrong bro we're like you don't gotta
hate me dude like it seems like we agree
on a lot of things and also my shit's
funny and I'm a God to you I need to
kiss my feet for suiciding a 2.3 million
follow our Twitter account because I'm
just that [ __ ] cool
laughs
yeah how does Hassan look like an R
order
I don't know if he said that I don't
want to put words in his mouth just
based off of this random chatter what a
[ __ ] Weasley little is that a serious
thing he looks or like he's talking
about something like what does that mean
I don't know I don't have the context
you said it I I just thought it was an
interesting uh tip from the chat and I'm
looking into it now I'm trying to find
it so we can actually see what he said
instead of doing what he did all right
putting words in his mouth all righty
people people never understand that Free
Speech doesn't entitle you to Freeman
freedom from consequences everybody
understands that it's like so obvious
everyone talked about it a thousand
times it's
so obvious everybody understands that
like you can you can say and have
opinions but as soon as you use that
platform for things that are against
their rules such as impersonating then
they're going to ban you you know that's
it's not stifling free speech that's I
never said it was bro he's the one that
said it that's why it was funny
enforcing their policies the thing that
goes against uh elon's claims of like a
champion of free speech where everyone's
thoughts
I got a call coming in oh don't
interrupt him he's making a good point
bro
oh we go to let Charlie speak he's the
only one with the [ __ ] brother
I love Charlie
oh yeah no worries
no Charlie you're way too nice with them
you keep them on way too short of a lead
you say no bro sit the [ __ ] down
you work once a week and I pay your I
cover I put in your kids through college
no phone calls
you can keep talking I'm kidding by the
way you dumb asses who are watching this
getting all crazy okay
just hang on do you want them do you
want them this is Awesome by the way
it's good
good show you muda just in case uh yeah
he's muted
right
she's dead
I just saw her yesterday
this is giving me quartering light by
the way up here
or maybe he's a little quartering I
don't know
but the whole vibe no fate
y all right this didn't go anywhere you
guys get the point where you get the
idea yeah shout out uh Charlie he's the
malevolent god dude it's all they need
to have shrines of Charlie in their
[ __ ] closets oh interesting look
Olivia says uh
yeah I guess Hassan has beef with this
guy Hassan has a whole video ripping on
this guy with the guy who was talking
[ __ ] about me or the guy I just like
quartering live no the guys he died yeah
yeah
and he feels a sun always with the right
takes it's a smart move
somehow we're always on the same page
how about the Turkish three streamer
Kaya Orson said about you he said that
you were a capitalist grifter after you
purchased your three million dollar
house yes indeed I could dude this guy
is such a [ __ ] idiot he even says
like is this guy friends with Charlie
because I'm about to go in on this guy
it's not essentially exactly okay good I
love that uh he's always right this
man's he's got a beautiful brain
dumb and he looked pretty good too
um
so I hear so this guy's just like a
contrarian like [ __ ] [ __ ] you know oh
he's Turkish so they have like the whole
Turkish uh rivalry
Hassan doesn't get along well with other
Turkish people
oh yeah it's a whole thing but learning
to be like that with Middle Eastern
people every time I see someone hate
it's always a middle eastern name and
I'm like be your own people
you don't like the association but but
turkey isn't I thought Turkish or
considered something else
are you talking about engines Middle
Eastern yeah I think still consider
Middle Eastern I could be wrong but I
don't know I mean me and Hassan both
shave our ass so I consider us the same
no yeah it's true you guys have not just
your app your everything yeah all the
way down yeah
that's fascinating
all the way down huh
how often do you upkeep it
uh
I don't know every few weeks I'm
I didn't speak up the other day when you
guys were talking about it but I was a
little confused what do you mean like
why what's the distinction all the way
down like what do you do well you can
like trim it right manscape bit
so like how much I mean like a number
two a number three like how much uh how
much you leave it on there yeah okay
gotcha versus going all the way down
which yeah is a preference obviously
there's nothing wrong with it some
people like the way it looks some don't
but I think the one thing is like um
it requires a lot more upkeep and also
it's gonna it's gonna irritate your [ __ ]
a lot more
that is for sure true I guess
very itchy if you go but so all the way
down you're only upkeeping it every
couple weeks though maybe it's got to be
growing out between them no my hair
grows slow
hmm okay
you're a lucky man dude there it is
there it is so I shave my face it takes
weeks to grow back and I hate that
you got that twink status yeah I don't
hate it it's annoying that's a coveted
status the twink status all right
thank you good for you bro
happy for you
thank you Hassan on the other hand I
know his [ __ ] is hairy as [ __ ] like he's
got to do some really frequent upkeep up
on that
interesting all right the time sense is
7 52 you said
now let's take a look
people are wondering if my mouse keeps
it keeps it uh nice and trim down there
people are really horny for my mouse
I've noticed hey your mouse they're like
really into it
DPI my pubes are perfectly trimmed 800.
TPI my pubes are are very smell very
good
oh
uh
wait what's happening he's watching
Contra points now I'm confused
I run the goddamn out
skip to 752 um he somebody in his chat
links them to the video okay he's about
to switch to it it feels bad too yeah if
that's Turkish as [ __ ] dude
what is this
I want to [ __ ] my DPI put my mouse in
your butthole
1600.
massage your pristine
no
no he will be accused of sexual assault
are you serious
why would you say that keep watching
what an [ __ ] you're so bitter and
jealous it's so obvious when your whole
career is thanks to Charlie you should
be sucking you should never talk [ __ ]
bro you just think about on your knees
deep throating Charlie if the fact that
you ever get a word out between blowing
Charlie is is too much you need to be on
his [ __ ] all day every day you know what
I mean that's how grateful you should be
to him
you could breathe and swallow his load
nothing else in between you have too
much free time
to express the Gratitude he deserves
do you see it you don't wear this kind
of [ __ ] unless you've done something
dude you're like actually
you're actually like
wow
okay I don't want to be mean but he's
sitting there in a v-neck t-shirt Way
Too Deep by the way and also the shirt
kind of slaps he goes yo this guy hates
racism bigotry patriarchy white yo white
supremacy what the [ __ ] inequality
oppression intolerance Injustice yo what
the [ __ ] son of a [ __ ] [ __ ] scumbag
mm-hmm
this is good man this guy's actually
this guy's actually a total idiot and I
love that this is corroborated somewhere
else
it's always the kind of oh what a
[ __ ] scumbag yeah
preach
I'm coping when socialist turns out to
be capitalist grifter bingo
oh brother this dude is like oh dude why
did you link this to me
brother yo
let me tell you something
do not go there okay every single one of
these [ __ ] uh douchebags that come
out of the [ __ ] Woodworks
are absolutely without a [ __ ] doubt
right now just so horny they're like
come on please let me get a [ __ ]
crumb of clout dude I can't suckle off
Charlie Enough by being on his podcast
on my own dude come on please
let me just put the [ __ ] straw down
on your
straw right down on the ground and just
oh God we're literally watching a
[ __ ] video about Envy no free clown
dude it's like he's not in the room for
you loud okay
I'll give him all the cloud he wants bro
I'm A Cloud all over his [ __ ] face
and he's gonna like it
I got no problem with giving up free
clout you know what I mean
he likes her you're against Free Speech
but you're into free clout hypocrite wow
isn't that what you said you always
hated wow wow I got enough clout to go
around my dude hey when you're done
sucking the clout from Charlie get over
here on your knees and I'll [ __ ]
don't feed you as well
I know it's vulgar but I'm just saying
the guy wants to go out and I'll give it
to him
I know it's vulgar sorry go off King
guy's just such a [ __ ] idiot and now
that I see he said this [ __ ] about my
boy Hassan now I'm fired up and Charlie
I love you by the way you're a good me
you're a saint I mean my God you gave
this man a career where else would he be
if not for you I mean genuinely
I don't know how representative this is
of um the entirety of Charlie's audience
but I have seen a lot of messages saying
that they have in the past
um watch Charlie's podcast and have
stopped because this guy is so annoying
I love that now that's just that's
whatever demographic overlaps between
Charlie and our podcast and so obviously
they're gonna lean more towards finding
this guy annoying but
yeah I watched it every now and then and
he does very often like take over and
push his opinion very much
yeah not he's not I could could say why
you would dislike him okay
what's his name Haya
foreign
you know what I mean like you need to
just be worshiping his feet where he
walks I mean genuinely she talk less
worship more okay okay Ethan that's just
the way it should be for you my dude
[ __ ] douchebag
I agree bro this is great that Aslan had
this I love it
I almost wonder all he talks about if he
had this previous dislike for Hassan if
you are catching you know collateral
damage from that because you're friends
with him a lot of people that's what I
was thinking yeah a lot of people you
guys cross over right yeah our haters
grew stronger when we made leftovers
right because I had like dedicated
haters and he had dedicators it turned
into like a super group right they're
just so passionate oh yeah I swear to
God man the people that hate me are so
passionate they really are and you find
them all over the Internet these days
you know
it's kind of a cliche thing but it it it
maybe means you're doing a little
something right I don't know like I mean
you're very opinionated on the internet
you don't hold back and I get why and
you tend to hate people who hate you
back you know yeah I pissed off a lot of
fandoms okay and obviously I'm very
harsh as you can see I'm talking about
this [ __ ] loser idiot
and um but at the same time what I don't
like is just people willing to believe
like just outright insane things he's
saying about me it's like it's so silly
I'm just sitting back I just can't allow
that [ __ ]
God is killing pedos and the one main
thing he always brings up is pedos oh is
he like some [ __ ] Q Anon freak
oh a lot of people that are like
constantly talking about pedophile oh by
the way I just saw this message thank
you so much Kaylee almost two years of
being a member wow hey it must have been
one of the first yeah we didn't really
launched it yeah pretty much two years
ago I think it was like August 20th yeah
but we didn't really start building it
out until
somewhat recently right this year
anyway
thank you so much true true fuper
trooper right there
Amelia are um you know
very weird
I'm hoping if Charlie she's all that
he'll say something because the Dude is
generally good at not taking people's
[ __ ] but if he's on the podcast even
with all the weirdo [ __ ] he said there's
not much hope element fail
oh [ __ ] whoa whoa people are coming
through the woodwork now 20 oh my God
okay people are like no I've been subbed
for there's a lot of projects
okay because I think he's weird but I'm
losing the point Okay evan 35 months 35
how's that even possible we had or I
guess you guys had it on for way before
we started yeah there was like it got
activated but he just left Brett left a
message 27 months 27. dude 30 30. how
did you do that where you logged into
your account 35 might be the longest
I've seen what is it where are you
logged in no I'm just log into my
account because I have YouTube premium
and it doesn't let me add YouTube
premium to my work account and so like
when I'm like fact checking stuff I get
ads all the time if I don't use my main
account cam grants 27 months yo okay
thank you everybody
um thank you everyone hey 27 months see
you guys are [ __ ] amazing y'all thank
you you guys make such a difference I'm
seeing what's going on in the chat and
there's so many loyal Super Troopers out
here just
dozens of months 24 10 17. I don't even
know that's crazy y'all are going nuts
right now
let's see represent holy God damn 25 24
23 [ __ ] dang God damn
can you see who's I just sent mine uh 17
months for me wow fake fan
you're not going to read all this all
their names Ethan it's like it's like 20
per Jesus
holy [ __ ] I've ever seen a I don't think
I've ever seen it go faster that's
insane thank you guys that's insane
you guys are all kings and queens of my
heart
Super Troopers forever
and [ __ ] uh Kaya or Haya
Kaya yeah which is sadly a beautiful
name
great song too yeah shut up shout out
Bob shout out Bob Marley yeah
um
what did I just thank you guys this is
insane it's going so fast I can't I know
there someone made a donation but
there's no way I'm gonna be able to see
it yeah I'm trying to get back
my pants off
[ __ ] YouTube chat dude I really hope
that someday soon YouTube uh does some
kind of prime ask membership thing
yeah I thought a lot about that and I
don't what do they tie it in with a
little uh uh YouTube music
yeah Youtube music It's like 10 or 12 a
month it's a great service I use it
connected to YouTube premium and if you
do that then you get one free membership
donation or whatever why not it's three
bucks well how much does it cost to uh
subscribe to um
YouTube music last I checked it was 10
but I think they raised it
oh it's 10. it's like five bucks a month
and they no it's it's includes YouTube
music I think interesting so it's
actually a really good deal because
Amazon Prime is 15 a month so you have
to imagine when they give a free sub to
somebody on Twitch they're paying them
350 right minus their cut or whatever
it's 350 out of 15. so that's why I was
curious how much
the YouTube or how much is even well
premium twitch has 50. is 9.99 a month
and they have a one month free trial
9.99 a month dude I'm telling you I
don't know why YouTube does such a bad
job pitching it it's 10 bucks a month
you get YouTube music which is the same
as Spotify and all this [ __ ] they have
all the new release all the new music
and you get ad for YouTube it [ __ ]
rules
yeah maybe they should I don't know why
I keep saying it's such a great service
I love it right yeah and you can premium
is load videos 12 bucks a month
which isn't that much less than uh the
15 per Prime yeah they're they're
missing out on that because I try to
even tell them I was like let's work
together I feel like I could promote the
[ __ ] out of this and they're like no
dude we don't give a [ __ ] about Ethan
he's a [ __ ] I was like really wow
straight up I was like I've been on
YouTube for a long time they're like
[ __ ] you they call me a Jew and I was
like dude whoa this is your CEO
they were like openly anti-semitic he
said I would spit in your face if you're
in front of me right now I was like dude
I'm just trying to help the Jews
damn
yeah they're crazy
um thank you to
thank you to Cecily uh 10 gifted subs
thank you so much love you Rory Hicks
been watching since the Vape Nation days
no mention of them all people what Rory
you dropped the whole stick
we had a good thing going on there man
people
L Susan I know man
and even more specifically the Jews
thank you Amy good job Chris says Susan
is an Uncle Tom is there more to this uh
regular I think he's kind of like the
healing machine
we have different policies on this kind
of thing it's true
so there it is you know I'm getting
tired of seeing these these just stupid
takes it's just not fair that they can
say whatever the [ __ ] they want so I
gotta say what I came back oh what's up
tater tots clown oh those clown emojis
are for Andrew Tate right dude all the
tater tots are in my Tick Tock chat
yo y'all are in my chat right now
they're literally just spamming clown
emojis like y'all are just watching my
show right now you know that right
no you know Tick Tock is crazy right now
shut up some people are spamming hard
some people are just flaming clown
emojis there's a whole battle what's
going on in your life that you just sit
on the live of a guy doing a podcast
with this phone set up next to him so
you can only hear like
30 of the show and just spamming the
clown Emoji all not a lot like what what
are you doing get on Hustler University
bro there's all kinds of [ __ ] to learn
it's like a little bit Andrew Tate
literally says if you cook you're
wasting time so how are you justifying
this literally even comments I actually
think explicitly this is what he said
isn't a waste of time right like well he
does I'm currently on his Discord he
tells people to Bill Gate right so so
like that time but cooking is that's the
game got it have you guys seen The Solar
opposite show where there's like humans
in the wall like in a big aquarium I
don't know when I seen it I actually
haven't seen it that's Justin Rowland's
show though yeah but so it's like they
shrink a bunch of human and they put it
in like an aquarium and it's like a huge
sob story I feel like the tater tots in
your phone is like just
shrunken down people
yeah and they have their whole thing in
there but they have no impact on the
real real world right
this person who's spamming clown emojis
just wrote you're obsessed to me
dude you're in your you're in my chat
idiot like I'm not even aware of you or
anything about you
you guys are awesome man thank you guys
for being here we have actually a lot of
people in The Tick Tock chat so this is
great thanks for being here guys
appreciate that yo I got a crazy yo
people can do all kinds of crazy
Graphics we love that all right thank
you Tater Tots can they still uh respect
people still throw uh tomatoes on Tick
Tock yeah yeah that's still like a thing
yeah and you can pay to do that they
don't they're not doing that you should
tell them
they don't eat I would hate if you
started throwing Tomatoes at me that
would be so [ __ ] up I see fans putting
cool ass ones they're super crazy hey
tater tots don't throw tomatoes at me
that would really hurt my feelings ah
mess up my whole show
someone just did a kawaii one on me I
love that thank you yeah so anyway
that's that I'm I I had to clear the air
and I'm Sorry Charlie for going hard on
your boy because you know you didn't
you're a good man you didn't say
anything uh so but no no
disrespect but your boy needs to shut
his [ __ ] mouth and just start
knobbing your knobbing you harder
because you got you leave them on two
too much leash on that thing and he just
he gets in trouble he's like you know
what I mean he's like an untrained
he's not potty trained
um Angie oh wow I just got baited
how so
I just got baited
somebody donated two dollars to Philly D
just dropped a new Ethan Klein thumbnail
and I rushed over
oh wait a minute maybe it just hasn't
updated yet sometimes yeah sometimes it
doesn't happen because the reason I
thought I got baited is the most recent
one has Hassan that's from yesterday
right that says one day ago no he has
two he has a new video with Ethan's name
in the title okay what did I do okay
Andrew Taylor where's Alex Jones versus
Ethan Klein oh just he's just baiting
because of the Twitter they got unbanned
and I didn't
let's see what he said maybe I I wanna I
wanna ride for Philly today I feel like
I want to be homies with Philly today
maybe is this a good idea
I love Philly Nothing's Gonna Come on
he's my boy yeah we yeah it's always fun
to watch Philly these videos live
but can you go back to his page he's got
so many Hassan thumbnails what the [ __ ]
yep pull that [ __ ] up again [ __ ] have
you guys been hearing the Sunday wraps
he has a dude wrap the news from that
week hell no he's not what yeah go to
the one from a day ago I've yeah the
truth about PewDiePie go to that one
dude Hassan is scoring big numbers it's
making me insecure I don't like yeah
it's he might
I mean I think
on a long enough timeline you probably
still being crowded but I don't know
2022
2022 but like lifetime I mean lifetime I
think you've definitely got it but also
as far as other deplorables who uh
likely will not come back to the
platform you have Ethan Klein still he
was banned after him Paul he was
deplorable that's funny it was funny I
like that impersonating musk also his
wife Ela got banned a few days ago this
after tweet from the account red this is
Ethan you [ __ ] loser Elon Musk I'm
bannivating LOL stop me now [ __ ] ass
loser and later defending that tweet
saying it was a joke on Ila's account
it's not even a real ban Invasion for
doing this saying why are you focusing
on this while Twitter is burning yeah
any and all thoughts you have it's fair
a tweet is funny this where's the
rapping though
that's the episode before wait oh is
this what he talked about today yeah
this is today's
oh okay cool yeah we love you Philly
you're a good man
he's a bit he's a great man he's skinny
he's skinny
so skinny
he looks amazing
skin is clean too I was about to say
this rock is routine he looks so hot
Billy text me your skincare routine bro
oh my God he looks so hot
today
the temperatures
what Olivia wasn't his old username Sexy
Phil yes oh oh it still is you can't
hide that [ __ ]
oh no no I think it's gone oh he got the
handle yeah on the Escape because it
always was Slash Sexy Phil how'd you
escape that film someone let you off the
hook with that one dude but let's bring
it back come on I won't forget
My Sexy Phil and you're more sexy than
you've ever been love his ass
[ __ ]
drop only fans bro
800 DPS where's the rap y'all want to
see the rap
Phil
can you imagine I have to assume royalty
free if he's putting you know
plus they probably end you with it in
four years I ain't seen no [ __ ]
say I'm missing The Apprentice so I
don't need a [ __ ] Grammy just enough
to buy Taylor ticket for my family pay
the 30k when people try to sell a
scalping put it into FDX and lose my
[ __ ] Camry oh God it's all right it's
actually it's actually fun I was
actually this is so I got a left field
but yeah it's pretty enjoyable honestly
I came here to goof but I thought it was
a fun time I'm afraid to keep playing
because I'm afraid they're gonna claim
it I like this no hate actually
stop stop
black cherry flavor
oh by the way so Dan you thought
here's another thing that just confused
me in the Ethan culture War that's
happening on the internet lately
um
they showed the tweet
I may or Ela made from her Twitter
account that got her band right
you said you thought that was funny
right yeah it cracked me up when I saw
it because I think I did if I recall
correctly I just didn't see that you
were talking about in the chat so I just
got the notification on my phone from
Mila and then saw that okay because this
was posted on the subreddit I noticed
there's a sub at cringe topia
and again
I'm just so confused by the world lately
top of the I guess week I don't know
um uh so yeah the cringe Topia uh
subreddit there's it's one of those
I don't know why I know this my my brain
is poison with internet knowledge but
basically cringe our cringe was the
original on Reddit and then it became
too woke for some so cringe Topia was
created and cringe Topia was so wait
insanely toxic that it actually got
banned off of Reddit and then they
remade it which is the subreddit that
got posted onto wait I don't see it did
it
but I just saw one that caught my Andrew
Tate on drugs
for cars more private jets Welcome to
the Real
dollars a year and guess how much I
spend of the 10 million [ __ ] all
blasted wait is this copyrighted music
dude he's on crap what is wrong I don't
know what's going on I've never seen
this I've never seen his eyes so but
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait he
says he makes 10 million dollars a year
he puts Ford he makes a lot more than
that I thought he made way more he's
poor that's what he yeah exactly that's
what I thought oh no I actually I
calculated from his Discord he made like
5 million a month he had like what was
it 100 000 members with fifty dollars
that's so crazy we'll assuming yeah
there's that many suckers in the world
uh-huh it was they say they're born
every minute yep yeah
what is this what is he on
wait why did my post get deleted I'm so
confused it was like Banger it was like
top post of the week I don't know could
anyone find a link because I found it on
the subreddit
yeah it had it had like 3 000 upvotes
dude it was like the top post so maybe
our fans were brigading it so they
deleted or something
what why would they care these guys are
like uh
that they're like
nihilus or whatever the [ __ ] they're
nihilus Donnie they don't believe in
anything yeah
um
I'd like to know why it usually says why
it was array so I'm kind of curious
what it says
that's very interesting very very
interesting very interesting
damn yeah anyway everyone was like the
title is this I'll just show it unless
if we can't find it I have it on screen
over here it says uh this is a 37 year
old man with millions of subscribers
and it was number one
and I was like
is this I don't know is this crazy I
don't know maybe maybe without the
context it's crazy maybe like if you
don't I don't understand the context at
all I mean it's very immature it's not
not that the people that hang out on the
cringe Topia subreddit are uh you know
necessarily the most developed minds or
anything but but like it was universally
accepted oh yeah this is crazy because
it had like it was the top post because
it's a weirdo like griper subreddit of
course I mean they don't like you oh
someone said it got voted Chad and then
they had to erase the post because it
got voted Chad is that a real thing yeah
and um and again because you you saw
this because it got cross-posted to our
subreddit right yeah yeah so it that's
what I was saying is like I'm sure the
agency got in there and uh that's wait
how do all you guys know so much about
this server there's so many people who
are like yo no I got Chad that's kind of
a serve honestly I do you feel like a
Chad I do yeah all the time your time
every time I look in the mirror
um yeah and by the way I'm 42. that was
what the post said on the subreddit
right like uh he's 42 for the record oh
my God old man no I'm 37. at least these
guys who hate me respect my [ __ ] age
they don't do this this Aegis [ __ ]
you guys do this joke we're celebrating
no you're not celebrating celebrating
these guys they are showing me more
respect than you are 37. I think it's
disrespectful to yourself just play into
this delusion where you're lying to
yourself about your age like I know it
helps your ego you want to see my
driver's license it's not fair to you
yeah I do I'll get it you want me to get
my driver's license you have to try and
prove something that we know isn't true
this is this should go on cringstopia
right here man will not accept his age I
don't know what to tell you guys but I'm
gonna go kick it with cringe Topia
remastered because these guys know how
to respect my age I'm like you freaks
okay on my Chad so thank you to cringe
Topia there it is we love it yeah I just
I was like why is this
I I was just like what is going on I I
just didn't understand it I mean and
trust me I'm I'm happy to accept when
I'm cringe and when I'm embarrassing and
all that like it happens from time to
time and I'm fully aware of it but that
I thought
I don't know I feel like another thing
I'm just getting done Dirty by people
I guess without the context you know I
don't know whatever [ __ ] them I'm a Chad
on your own subreddit
oh next
World Cup
World Cup's [ __ ] that organization is
one of the most corrupt in the world
people know that right it's
very uh understood yeah that FIFA is uh
not on the up and up it's actually quite
staggering just how openly corrupt they
are um
I think when Qatar was originally
awarded
to hold FIFA hold the World Cup hold the
World Cup everyone was understandably
a little confused because one it's
[ __ ] unbelievably hot there right
although it's the winter how hot is it
it doesn't matter there's a I have
there's a video in the talk of um some
fans that were staying there and it was
uh
they showed their phone it was 29
Celsius which uh I believe is oh in the
Tent City yeah that's 84 degrees
Fahrenheit
um that's and that was like first thing
in the morning I got hotter from there
by the way Charlie broccoli donated 20
and said happy 42 birthday my dude yeah
um Claire sorry was Claire now Claire
I'm gonna refund that okay and um
I'm gonna erase that okay shame on you
when did you you said that last week
during see you next Tuesday you said
that you were
your birthday
I may have said that yeah
so um before I get into this there's
actually lots of funny and good and
actually tragic and awful stuff here but
it's entertaining I gotta pee
I'm oh thank you I just got a piece so
okay and I'll be right back you can just
should we just get you a diaper and I
gotta we actually have adult diapers
over there cool are you good oh
well I had a guy pee on me once there's
that photo evidence of it yeah which we
still don't understand where it came
from I gotta get to the bottom of it
yeah actually this might be a good time
at many of you out there in the audience
probably remember this photo of Ethan
diaper
pause to pee
um here it is favorite yeah and look it
came up on Google images from uh Lauren
Chen uh who is a right-wing weirdo
um posting this does anybody remember
the context of this photo let's put this
on a milk carton and get the figure
because Ethan doesn't remember and
neither do any of us so
okay
um somebody just donated two dollars and
said is Bradley Martin still coming on
yes it's been rescheduled too I believe
not this Friday but the following Friday
is that right let's GoGo the diaper
Doritos Bandit
IMDb has a h3h3 Productions Ethan Klein
as self in Bobo the diaper Doritos
Bandit
so Boba skin bags of Doritos the diaper
Bandit
uh I don't
no there's a video titled that that has
nothing to do with H3 so I don't know
why that's on why is
that a [ __ ] clue
uh uh Dan I said Chad earlier asking
about wakanda forever and your thoughts
on Neymar I don't know anything about
either of those things
so I'm sorry thank you for the ten
dollars though I know that's probably
disappointing uh I I haven't seen the
new Black Panther movie has anybody
here I have not no
yeah it's out I heard Black Adam was
[ __ ] there's a side note I've um
I've pretty much written off Marvel like
I was never huge into MCU but like I
mean I'm not gonna act like I always
hated it I I've enjoyed plenty of Marvel
movies some more than others but after I
haven't really felt anything they've
done after those Avengers movies like
it's just it's too much like they they
needed to they needed to just pause for
a few years let let people miss it so
and I'm sure some of it's good but I
I've just I've not been able to be
enticed to give a [ __ ] about any any of
the uh post Avengers stuff
I choked on a junior man
oh no that's the way to go how would you
call this box I'm trying to find out how
many calories in this uh one side size
box or yeah something like that Junior
mint bite size box calories anything I
mean what are we doing 130 wait Junior
Mints theater candy box no that's a
whole box
only 130
it's pretty good that can't be right
it's 80.
Junior mint your candy of choice one box
of one size is 80 calories ah why am I
choking I like Junior Mints I don't put
my candy of choice but that's Pro Junior
Mints Pro
it's up there for me somebody said don't
disrespect Marvel okay I'm sorry I'm
sorry about that dude how's someone
gonna
write spoiler with a super chat and just
spoil what the [ __ ]
it was a Dan donated ten dollars the Zoe
experience Dan did you get your tickets
for the king giz at the Hollywood Bowl
[ __ ] yeah dude
um pick those up the other day remember
I think I remember now the diaper photo
yeah completely click the I want to read
this tweet it's one of these yeah I know
it's funny because uh
somebody said oh that's uh all the right
wing people's favorite photo and that
was the first result in Google Images
was from uh Lawrence from this [ __ ] she
says oh can't see it anymore because
you're banned ah loser l
go down trust experts on health like
this guy I actually don't look that bad
here right you're not really I was a lot
that's great I mean it's like a normal
body healthy I'd be concerned if my
doctor walked in like that yeah true
fair I think that was right after Ela
gave birth
yeah and she had diaped she had diapers
because you know [ __ ] gets pretty wild
down there in the recovery phase oh
after Theodore yeah
put them on just for a laugh I see
and uh posted it somewhere I think to
Instagram
well is it still on your Instagram it
would be do you see it there I guess let
me go maybe a story I don't know maybe
there's a story thing
it was a vertical wasn't it so yeah it
probably was a story actually I'm sorry
guys but that's confidence bro I dare
you to post a picture of yourself in
your wife's diapers okay
literally
unbothered
oh
Sam just said oh my God are we in
trouble tomorrow we're filming the
special Thanksgiving and Ian sent this
message people will vomit tomorrow I'm
being so foul oh great Sam that's you
the [ __ ] did you do cool are you gonna
be eating any of this Sam
we're gonna have a talk I don't know if
I agree with the rules it is written
yeah I think we might need to make a
revision there
Sam you're gonna have to taste this [ __ ]
yeah
she says okay I just heard a giggle from
behind the curtain
all right so let's talk about World Cup
here um yes the World Cup has begun do
you guys care about the World Cup are
you watching this [ __ ] uh you in
thoughts
uh yeah I like it yeah I called him well
Ian just he likes soccer he's into
soccer I'll tune in for the World Cup
it's like a it's a low-level commitments
once every four and would you say that
um
what would you say uh is gonna happen
with England wait somebody actually
sorry but somebody said it's from a
video this person knows better than me
it's from an old H3 video
where he did a reaction
video about adults wanting to pretend to
be a baby
that sounds right to me that's the name
call I probably have in the video I have
all the videos the diaper Doritos Bandit
I'm pretty sure dude
oh my God what the [ __ ] oh my God okay
what the hell did you show
oh my God it's from your first video
Jesus love
erase that
yeah yeah
no it's not up it's not up I have the
only surviving archive oh interesting
whatever the Lore Master yeah so um
world cup is beginning FIFA president
Gianni Infantino head out
a criticism of Qatar from Europe on the
eve of the World Cup recalling his own
experience of bowling as he aligned them
with other experiences of being gay oh
this is so good you guys this is this is
the best so right out right out the gate
um
we're serving
great great stuff I guess maybe we give
a little bit more context for those that
are unaware so the this world cup is
getting a lot of criticism because it's
taking place in Qatar which is a they
have like a state that is a uh literal
absolute monarchy
um and there was a lot of controversy
because they were doing
they were accused of bringing in migrant
workers mostly from India and Pakistan
and places in South Asia and once they
got there essentially kidnapping them by
taking away their passports so they
couldn't leave and forcing them to work
in horrible conditions and it's been
estimated that in building all of the
stadiums and everything for the World
Cup something over 6 500 workers died in
accidents and because of poor working
conditions and stuff so they've been
getting a lot of [ __ ] and a lot of
people think that they really only got
awarded the World Cup because they
bribed officials of FIFA obviously right
yeah and this is something I've been
saying about the gulf countries forever
like people keep going to Dubai and
celebrating like this great place they
literally have slaves there they built
on slave laborers they have migrants
come there they confiscate their
passports these people are sick [ __ ]
animals this place has been marked and
violated forever I'll never go to Dubai
that place is just disgusting they hate
gay people you can't you can't be you'll
die there they'll like kill you would
you be able to go to Dubai even if you
wanted to I can't no because I I'm
Israeli yeah I was about to say I don't
think they let it's really American one
but it has Israeli stamps they probably
just why I just just don't yeah it just
seems like a bad idea they just execute
me at the uh at the checkpoint
um can you by the way as I'm watching
this can you try to find the clip of
them saying no Kosher food and no Jewish
prayer uh okay
yeah so here he is this guy uh so good
you guys and I hope you have that sound
bite ready AB today
I have very strong feelings
I can tell you that
today I feel um
Qatari
hmm
wow
today I feel Arab wow I felt gay today I
feel African okay oh wow okay well crazy
so who is gay today I feel uh gay well
well just today
you are gay
[Music]
today I feel disabled oh come on
today I feel
a migrant worker oh
all right let's get out there with a
hammer and get to work I felt that note
of good like that was based on what they
told me he's taking his time with us
all this
because what I've been seeing and is
what I've been told but I've been told
since I don't dream
okay
I felt worthless
well they see inspired by FouseyTUBE
to my personal story what is what the
[ __ ] I'm not gonna watch it what the
[ __ ] is his point I felt ugly he opens
with it so where's this going okay so he
has a couple points he says
um one uh all of the horrible things
that Europe did over the last 3000 years
gives them no place to uh say anything
bad about what's going on in these Gulf
States you did that yeah uh he says that
a lot of money dude why does that make
him feel gay
I I don't know
that part was not really clear to me
um and then he also says he's basically
saying
uh
the government of Qatar is being bullied
and he knows what that feels like
because he was a redhead oh my God bro
he knows how to feel because he's what
because he was a redhead
well he doesn't have hair but he was
saying when he was a kid he had red hair
and he was bullied for that so he kind
of knows what it's like for the uh uh
dude that guy is the most bald man I've
ever seen I think he is the most single
most bald person alive it tastes like
beef jerky so maybe Howie yeah good
point yeah we might have that I don't
not a trace of red
um I felt that note like that he's
definitely got bribed like look at you
dude yeah you have no shame it's
actually insane I felt gay I felt like a
handicapped oh he felt like a guy a
migrant slave
I feel like a a giant penis today
I feeling all kinds of the I feel it
today autistic I thought today I'm
feeling like hungry I felt ugly just
everything I felt that note like the day
I was feeling a little hot and I had a
water
okay interesting go on
that's today I was a little uh felt a
little bored so I put on the TV okay
go off
today I felt like a pedophile priest oh
come on
everything well they've been bullied too
the church has been bullied no I'm
specifically pedophile priests they know
what it's like
I like being a redhead or a pedophile
priest you know know what this is like
or being the Emir of a oil State and uh
thank you by the way to Fouseytube who
helped me with this speech he's a good
man bruh I feel like my identity theft
I feel like it's happening
foreign
yeah this guy's an idiot what a stupid
idiot what idiot
so that's the president so this guy's
like a mob I mean he's like a mobster
practically at this point
so this is responsible previous head of
FIFA
go to jail for Christ I think he's the
replacement I think he's the guy who got
so I'm not a big uh football guy I think
you're doing a little hazy on this
hey today I feel like a gay or I'm a gay
man with autism
tomorrow I feel normal again it's okay
see yeah so this speech was in
Revelation to the uh story breaking that
6500 migrate works from India Pakistan
other countries have died in Qatar since
it won the right to host the World Cup
10 years ago that's [ __ ] insane that
is insane
today I feel like a diet of immigrant
worker who died
and today I feel like a [ __ ] like a
today I feel like I
and Charlie's co-host who [ __ ] sucks
for cloud
I feel so powerful
yeah whatever uh so the mascot of the
event is the ghost of all the dead
immigrant workers
interesting let's take a look
no shot bro
what what dude that tweet is a fire why
is it only at four thousand likes I
don't know but it made me laugh so I had
to throw it in there but
so what what do you what is the mascot
I'm assuming someone with a with like
the traditional yeah I mean I just do
that part of it it's Habiba like Casper
it's a baby Casper uh what is it though
well there's a description of what it is
in the uh yeah the story of the mascot
is weirder than any joke
we're delighted to unveil La IB as the
official mascot
for the first FIFA World Cup in the
Middle Eastern Arab world he comes from
the mascot verse play it it's cursed a
place that is Indescribable
Indescribable we encourage everyone to
imagine what it looks like we are sure
fans ever will love this fun and playful
character that's it
he's from the mascot first dude y'all
[ __ ] yell paid oh God damn like what
billions of dollars for this [ __ ]
I love him I I hope the next World Cup
takes place in the mascot verse to be
honest with you that's it that's all you
guys got what that they're like we don't
know what it is
the power is yours I love it y'all
figure this [ __ ] out because we don't
have any idea
yeah definitely the collective ghost of
the Dead migrant workers is so funny and
good and perfect
Qatar spent an estimated 220 billion in
prepare preparation for this building
not just stadiums but entire
neighborhoods skyscrapers and
transportation systems dude this whole
like um
melee to get the rights to have the
World Cup is so strange to me because
like last time I was in Brazil right in
the same time yeah and where they they
wasted so much [ __ ] money and now
they have like these abandoned stadiums
in the middle of like
totally uninhabited rainforest uh rural
lands like why do they want it so bad I
don't get it they really go make money
they spend 220 billion dollars to
prepare for this what's the height I
don't get it who wants me to take their
money
like actually I don't get it does anyone
know
I don't know I guess like traditionally
if you go to a country that has like the
existing infrastructure for it then I
guess you know you get a ton of Tourism
and generate a lot of money but if
you're going to Brazil or Qatar
there's no shot they're making
there's no shot they're making money
they're looking for World exposure yeah
I mean it does perhaps launder their
reputation yeah and it's not helping
them questionable questionable strategy
if that is it oh the next World Cups in
the USA oh that's cool where I think
it's like all over the country oh that's
exciting that's fun which I think is
more typical
so they say Ethan you're thinking of
Olympics not World Cup am I
what's the oh wait where was the last
World Cup was Brazil the Olympics
the last World Cup was in Brazil so wait
I am right yeah I don't know what
they're talking about
okay whatever yeah so okay that's fun in
America we're gonna have the World Cup
see that's actually a quote for America
because I know America's been trying to
get involved in the World Cup people
here don't really care about soccer or
football that much
and so I see why America would want that
and having a bunch of Tourism I was
actually not just the US it's all it's
United States Canada and Mexico jointly
yeah and the events will be uh here
here's all of the places it will be
last World Cup was in Russia actually it
wasn't Russia the prior one was in
Brazil I believe hurts nobody yo check
this out Skype is [ __ ] benefits
everybody they're gonna have a game in
Los Angeles damn that's gonna be nuts
oh great it's going to take us five
hours to get home definitely gonna be a
hell storm here for that yeah
cool well this is exciting this is cool
yeah but the thing is in all these
cities they're going to they have
established infrastructure and big ass
stadiums already existing they don't
have to build like everything from the
ground up right yeah yeah Los Angeles
actually has
two soccer stadiums now yeah I heard
they're probably the next uh World Cup
after this in Antarctica which is makes
total sense cozy economy antarcticans
have put in a compelling bid thank you
all righty love that
so uh 220 billion dollars Qatar is a
borderline absolute monarchy ruled by
the fan althani family yes yes yes we
love them good people the alphannies
um here is actually
we here's a little more context on the
mascot why is everybody keep everybody
keeps spamming about the sound bites
being too loud they're I can barely hear
it it's not I think they're trolling
because it's maybe too soft it's
possible that
no it's possible if you can't roll the
Flocka you can't roll the [ __ ] I don't
know maybe the audio sounds like you're
too loud with people you better turn it
down maybe I don't want people no I'm
just kidding people are like literally
spamming about how loud it is I haven't
touched anything uh Ian you need can you
like you're hearing the stream sound so
we don't like loud I think
people are saying sound bites they like
a really loud annoying one
um let's play the Flocka thing excuse me
play Yoko Ono [ __ ] it doesn't sound
loud it sounds completely [ __ ] fine
everyone are you is anyone monitoring
the levels of the show live I am yeah
okay so you can hear it it does not
sound loud at all but everyone now I'm
saying not loud everyone's like
soundtrack it sounded uh low to me but I
didn't touch anything because I don't
want what was going on I don't know
literally everyone's saying something
different in the chat so yeah
it's fine it seems like maybe some
specific sound bites are louder turn
your headphones down those are all Zach
there's your solution guys those are all
Zach famous for me
all right guys let's uh please I have an
important image here on the screen okay
this gives an important context to the
mascot that perhaps we're missing
I mean he had beautiful flowing red hair
and I think it was inspired by that so
I would never bully this beautiful man
here oh yeah come on
gorgeous
yeah so uh think of tick tock
tick people on Tick Tock are making
videos about Qatar World Cup camp
they cause a 175 pounds of 210 dollars a
night this is crazy bro
they have like basically straight up
immigrant as we stay the night this is
like the World Cup
these are like disaster camps like FEMA
disaster camps that they have people
staying
so yeah 200 a night check this out man
I mean this is what I'm saying it's like
I don't know that they're ready for all
this and they killed like 6 500 people
as we stay the night in one of the World
Cup fan camps in Qatar so one of these
tents is 175 pounds per night and it
took us a while to find reception but we
found it in the end this is us getting
shown to our tent
here we go Welcome to My Crib it says
pretty basic two single beds
um and the ground felt a bit bumpy so I
had a little inspection and just on Sand
y'all that is sand underneath there was
electricity and pretty decent Wi-Fi and
we had two padlocks to lock our tent So
This Is Us checking out the facilities
toilet unfortunately this area didn't
have any toilet paper um so we had to go
searching for that
I would maybe advise letting the water
run for a bit before you brush your
teeth yummy
what is saying good night night Nesta
whoever that is now we woke up the next
morning and the first thing that hit us
was the heat it was pretty hot in there
did have a fan though but at this point
what time did it say it was
on the phone
where's the time
it's it's in the middle it's too blurry
to see did have a fan though you're
talking about waking up in the morning
so I'm assuming it's relatively early
sleeping in there yep
that's hot the sun is like blasting it's
hot as [ __ ] it just felt like it was
pushing hot air around
we got a breakfast box in the morning
with a small bottle of water and an
instant coffee but there was nowhere to
fill up with hot water off for a shower
in the morning but unfortunately I
forgot to pack a towel and there was
none at reception
we had a bit more of a walk around and
it still felt slightly unfinished
considering there was two days before
the World Cup the staff assured us it
would all be open in time
is there any update videos from her
see I'll check right now
because uh
but yeah I mean [ __ ] that looks pretty
miserable
you know it's like a medieval Army cap
you could end up looking like this by
the end of it
[Laughter]
the ghosts of future is to come
Kaya tweeted oh is he tweeting about me
okay here we go
I'm about to clout you up brother
stop dick writing Elon also get your
facts straight before you talk [ __ ] okay
King three likes and let's see he got
all bothered about an anonymous tweet
with three likes that's me I'm Elon
Fanboy number one after talking about
his fantasies of unloading his shotgun
on people I hope he then doesn't end up
turning it on himself
that's a pretty [ __ ] yikes thing to
tweet also when did what okay hold on
let me read this again Jesus
that's [ __ ] up he's very angry he
could have just apologized for getting
it wrong
it was he says that's me Mr Elon Fanboy
his number one man
after talking about his fantasies of
unloading his shotgun on people when did
I ever do that
oh this is another weird cringe
right-wing conspiracy thing dude you are
so [ __ ] bro you are you see this is
this guy's an idiot yeah okay so we got
this this is another thing that's
floating around the internet this guy's
like the king of all the like bad faith
Ethan takes
so
I remember I made a video on Ethan and
the Ethan Klein Channel
about how oh yeah because
you're getting swatted and like I was
born and everyone was like oh you're a
[ __ ] because you don't believe in guns
and you wouldn't be able to protect your
family so all these right-wing [ __ ]
freaks are like
Ethan wouldn't protect his family
he's a coward and he wants to ban guns
oh right I said I believe in gun
ownership I own a gun and like if
somebody's gonna come here to hurt my
family I'll use it you could pull up the
clip and so then all these [ __ ]
idiots the same people who are like oh
you're a beta male who wouldn't defend
your family if somebody
came in try to pull that up it's from
Ethan Klein video
then they just clip that with like
creepy music and they're like Ethan
clients ready to kill people with a
shotgun like it's so crazy and so I he's
referring to that
so Kaya says after talking about his
fantasies of loan loading a shotgun of
people I hope Ethan doesn't end up
turning it on himself
yeah nice dude you're [ __ ] you're
actually like
that's a huge L tweet bro
that's very weird that's actually like
you can't even like address the issue
you just joking about me killing myself
in a really vulgar
freaky way
it's obviously very did they say it was
after Jeff wittick's friend showed up at
your house oh yeah yeah dude what's
wrong with you Doug
maybe maybe relax on the Alcohol I don't
know
what I mean I see other people saying
the same as after Jeff's friend thing
pull up the clip because that's another
thing I've never addressed that's just I
have it you got it yeah okay and then
try to find it on Twitter and Tick Tock
there's all these clips of me with
creepy music and they're like this guy's
[ __ ] mentally ill he wants to kill
people it's
just funny man
so you're in pretty deep into this Ethan
hate sphere
yes bro thank you for hoping I don't
kill myself with a shotgun thank you
brother
don't let Twitter break your brain okay
man I'm not on Twitter
dude you're gross bro you should really
be sucking Charlie's dick man
I'm talking right I think red flag laws
need to take effect where do you live
turkey I think
or maybe he moved from I was in Turkey
yeah
I didn't accuse you of being an Elon
Fanboy nice way to pervert what I said
though could you I I I accused you of
being a [ __ ] idiot bro which you
clearly have not done any work to try to
dispel
homie uh thank you uh homie get your
facts straight before you go ranting
just to be clear he's re that's he's
responding to the quote tweet the quote
tweet
said stop dick writing Elon
okay okay okay he's not saying you said
that no but he's saying that's me no he
says he's saying it sarcastically to the
person accusing him of being an Elon
Dick Rider okay so but he's saying he
got it from me I mean he says from that
after talking about his fantasy of
uploading shotgun people I hope Ethan
doesn't turn on himself he said he got
that idea for me
yeah I don't know
uh he says homie just get your facts
straight before you go ranting about a
topic you have no clue about don't say
on a podcast something Blake simply
wrong it's not that hard don't play the
victim thank you
could just apologize bro
oh what a nasty [ __ ] dude damn you are a
piece of [ __ ]
holy [ __ ] brother you're [ __ ] twisted
so here let me show you the video
that he's referring to
yeah here are you filming okay good art
on Twitter but this got this was making
the rounds a lot
Ethan Klein there's too many crazy
people with guns okay and then also
Ethan Klein watch okay you know
you went you do you live by the ratio
you die by the ratio it happens you know
sometimes you eat the barn sometimes the
bar eats you but if you do you do like
threatening with your wife
I will literally shoot you and kill you
okay so to say I'm against violence this
is how I sit in bed and I think
on my gun cabinet I I imagine how fast I
can get there yeah so so I was talking
about how traumatized it is to always be
worrying about people coming to my house
and so they cut it together so it looks
like I'm fantasizing about it but really
I was talking about how scary it is when
you always are afraid of people coming
to your house to harm you and I used to
be you know so paranoid at night
especially before I moved to my new home
when I was just living on like a normal
street that I would sit home and like
think about the gun lock because I was
so excited you could get to it and get
there right and be prepared yeah so they
cut that and put it afterwards like I'm
fantasizing about killing people nice
it's wild dude it's wild kill you okay
so to say I'm against violence this is
yo this is what he's talking about by
the way the dude who's like you know
spitting facts about Ethan the guy knows
everything about it I sit in bed and I
think about the rock combo on my gun
cabinet
imagine how fast I can get there or
punch in the code take out the gun turn
off the safety put the bolt in the
chamber and think about that obsessively
every night and that's the world I live
in okay so I'm not against violence when
it's necessary so punching a guy for
saying a stupid [ __ ] joke is not
necessary and if you want to test me
come to my [ __ ] house and I've got a
seven I've got seven bullets it's a
semi-automatic shotgun and I can unleash
seven [ __ ] bullets on you without
even have to [ __ ] that [ __ ] yeah I mean
I was just joking around at that part at
that point
but what was I talking about it was
something where someone got punched
retaliation or something Will Smith oh
yeah I was like dude that's so funny I
was like bro why you resort to violence
and they go look how crazy and violent
he is my whole point oh no I hope it's
not copyrighted
oh no I mean it could be oh no we're
gonna have to cut this whole part now
brick well we'll see yeah I didn't get a
I didn't get the warning how do you
copyright drums
there's a guitar too uh but usually it I
get that
heads up in the back end so yeah so if
you go watch the clip from my video and
contents is like right
it's not like that bro
but um
I'm actually glad he tweeted that out
it's funny I totally
was confused at first bar you're a
[ __ ] idiot dude
you actually managed to make yourself
look like bigger a [ __ ] piece of [ __ ]
than you already did
that's actually respectable in a way
props brother
props brother
I hope he doesn't [ __ ] kill himself
with a shotgun in his mouth what a
stupid son of a [ __ ] he said I was
wrong I hope he doesn't [ __ ] blow his
head off with a shotgun
stable genius
you're cool dude
yeah that's what I'm saying people they
watch that and they say Ethan's crazy
but if that was like Alex Jones they'd
be like based as [ __ ]
come on man well it's because you're a
hypocrite you're a [ __ ] hypocrite
you're a hypocrite
um
people say gloating I do actually I
think I actually do look kind of good
today kind of skinny and that shotgun
Club I look fat as [ __ ] boy [ __ ]
I had to have been right around your
your Zenith
yeah well right because uh it was like
right around Feb right well because you
got you got some uh
what's it called is it sympathy weight
or whatever during oh yeah
and that was right after Bruce was born
was that clip so I think I've been being
good for like three or four months maybe
I don't know how long it's been maybe
three months so yeah doing good thanks
guys wow congratulations you're fat
thank you
yeah I mean a good job baby yeah that's
a good one forgot it was AB for her not
Zach for a minute well done yeah this is
one of the first times I looked at
myself on camera and not wanted to puke
in my mouth
I'm just kidding it's not that bad I'm
not that serious
well that's an accomplishment actually
I think so I think so
it's better than you know getting fatter
at least you know for me that's what I
want right
so anyway uh thanks for the aside there
uh Kaya
Kyle's like my name's Kaya and I'm going
to tell you everybody to call themselves
no
playing words I'm desperately hold on do
I have a um I'm looking for the rim shot
please clap oh yeah guys can we get some
Rim shots please somebody sorry clap
those cheers
this one seems appropriate hold on
oh come on the horn I was the clap he's
the horn for the rest man you hater ass
[ __ ]
Caillou kill yourself he said
my name's Kaya and I want you to cook a
cake yourself
all right booze really guys
[ __ ] you Dan
that was gnarly tweet though that's kind
of like the gnarliest response you could
have isn't it to some criticism like
that yes
it's an interesting why is that a lie
about me it's just it's [ __ ] up and
it's wrong bro I hope you [ __ ] shoot
your own head off with a shotgun bro
also to be cool guys don't let Twitter
get to your head
yeah dude
moving on thank you for that
so
um did we have an update from that girl
on the Qatar uh infant or immigrant Camp
I'm not seeing it you know she there's
like five different accounts I just
reposted that video
I'm trying to find her original because
we got it from Reddit yeah and I need a
couple more things here like I want to
see the signs the posts they have of
like what to do what not to do they have
bands on alcohol and stuff I I want to
see all that stuff uh so the band there
was a blurb in there about the alcohol
no but I want to see the signs
okay social posts there's a bunch of
[ __ ] like that but I'll I'll keep going
until that yes so they told FIFA they
were gonna allow alcohol sale and then
two days before the event they are
Banning
the sale of alcohol
everywhere but in the high-end luxury
suites it's like you're not even gonna
totally bat it you're just gonna let the
rich people have it yeah of course it's
like why why the half
by the halfway
and actually I saw a clip maybe you guys
before that too
of uh I forget what country they're from
somewhere in South America I think and
they were all chanting like we want beer
or some [ __ ] it's funny
um
yo there's 800 what's going yo the the
[ __ ] chat is going crazy with Tate
tater tots biggest fall of YouTube L
there's 800 people in here they're all
tater tots I thought you died you're an
owl
dude you guys are awesome thank you for
the viewership Brothers thanks for
giving the show a chance I'm really glad
you guys are here
that's so cool thank you guys 900 now
dang you guys are rolling in thank you
guys so much so nice to see you thanks
for being here
so um in general the public Assumption
of alcohol is illegal in uh Qatar an
offense that can carry six months in
prison
anyone who's smuggling alcohol can face
three years in prison
speech that's deemed critical of the
Qatari government could trigger an
arrest we love that
those laws apply to both spoken and
social media posts homosexuality is of
course criminalized in Qatar
Advocates say the lgbtq people in Qatar
are subject to conversion therapy
harassment by authorities and
imprisonment
at a certain point
is it really that crazy to just say like
if you're if homosexually is illegal in
your country we're not going to have a
world event there like
hello
I mean am I wrong for that I'm not you
can you can respect the culture up to a
point I mean making get making
homosexuality illegal is like a human's
right violation why we got to celebrate
them for that
right it's like no we're boycotting you
Money Baby am I am I wrong though is
that is that like insensitive or some
[ __ ] I mean if you have [ __ ] migrant
slaves and homosexuality is illegal well
I mean it's entirely up to the
organization that's doing it FIFA
obviously does not care about that
that way you know
hey tater tots for watching come watch
the show you guys are gonna like it
we're having a good time I promise
I hope sensitive I'll teach you how to
be a man I'll take your hands
and they'll lovingly embrace it bruh
I'm gonna give you kisses at night
um
yeah I'm finding
tons of articles about this kosher food
thing but I can't find you're saying you
saw a thing where it's straight up there
was like a sign that was like no Jewish
food allowed I remember but it's
possible that I I was something else
like here here's this okay because I'm
finding lots of info yeah Qatar won't
allow cooked kosher food uh in public
Jewish prayer that I'm seeing a lot of
stuff about it but I I can't find any
like images that represent that
oh here's the uh
the Ecuadorian fans cheering how much
they want beer the uh ecuadorians are
just like [ __ ] this dude
um here it is
you can't have sober people watching
soccer they're really so [ __ ] boring
it is
just like you gotta keep them drunk
[Music]
it's so loud you can't even hear it but
can you find the one of the infograph
where it's like all this [ __ ] is banned
don't do this respect the culture it was
like a whole PR thing they were doing of
respect our culture
and one of the things was don't be gay
swear to God it said no homosexuality
they said respect our culture don't be
gay I mean I believe that that's their
policy but that was on their PR thing
they did this whole thing about respect
the culture
here is it this Qatar welcomes you
this is probably what you saw this is it
yeah so these are signs they put up and
I also saw they have on a thing on
Twitter or social media a whole PR thing
hopefully you can find that as well guys
it says respect reflect your respect
that's what it's called they did a
campaign look that up reflect your
respect okay to the religion and culture
of Qatari people by avoiding these
behaviors look at this drinking alcohol
homosexuality they says respect our
culture by not being gay
immodesty yeah okay
apparently you have to cover up your
whole body from neck
to toe which I have more tolerance for
than don't be gay obviously profanity
you're at a [ __ ] soccer match you
idiot yeah good luck you can't host the
World Cup and tell people oh by the way
don't curse watch your profanity watch
your profanity my voice cracked up
yeah I love that guy
I don't know it is so weird that this is
like
accepted by most people that it's crazy
I think it's [ __ ] up it even they're
covering up like forcing women to cover
up that's the issue right like forcing
and I can it's so weird it's crazy you
can't have
you can expect the world to participate
look to a degree I understand that
they're like look we're religious you
know it's respectful if you could cover
up
um like but the requesting people dress
modestly is reasonable yeah but don't be
gay is [ __ ] up like that's just insane
I'm seeing a lot of Articles linked to
an Instagram and Twitter posts and I
think they deleted it yeah it's all been
nuked I'm having this whole problem yeah
oh but what about reflect your respect I
was trying to reflect my respect I think
they were getting lots of hay for it I'm
trying to find here I think I found a
screenshot of one of their posts about
the dress code
oh no this guy went there with a rainbow
flag dude you're gonna get killed out
there
that important this guy said
this guy said just now security guy
refusing to let me into the stadium for
U.S whales you have to change your shirt
it's literally just a rainbow
yeah you're like rainbows are banned
you are gay
um and so actually it was responded to
but whoever the [ __ ] this is this tweet
got over 200 000 likes
he said as a guitar I'm proud of what
happened I don't know when will the
westerners realize that their values
aren't Universal there are other
cultures with different values that
should be equally respected let's not
forget that the West is not the
spokesman for Humanity how about this
how about you suck my [ __ ] dick you
homophobic freak and how about we
boycott your whole [ __ ] country Until
you realize that you're being that you
are violating human rights how about
that how about [ __ ] that country bro
that's what I'm saying the gulf
countries are [ __ ] the people they could
be grabbed not but the governments that
this whole like being gay is illegal I'm
sorry but that [ __ ] is ancient [ __ ]
history and I'm not down with it to any
degree we can't pretend like that's
normal dude you know why because they
need religion to control the people so
they can steal more money from them I
think that's where it leads back to and
when the further that they go away from
religion the less control the government
has to keep the poor poor and the rich
rich just saying that's kind of been the
traditional role of uh
religion in the Christian you know if
you're going back so they're still
keeping it going oh don't pull up the
oil reserves Dan I'm just saying this is
why what you just said will never happen
okay okay maybe maybe hate to get maybe
it's fine if they hate gay people
how much oil do they have yeah [ __ ] gay
people you're right [ __ ] it yeah [ __ ]
how much dirt how much 25 25 million a
day trillion I [ __ ] man I respect
their culture it's their choice they
could yeah being gay it's a choice
choose not to be gay 25 million barrels
look at this
this is their reserves and it's 25 uh
25 trillion wait no 25 billion 25
billion yeah 25 billion okay how much
oil okay
[ __ ] you dude get out of the stadium
freak
you freak you prom you you provocateur
how dare you
how much are they have
um execute them [ __ ] it
I love you I am not a gay man wait how
much would you say they have how much
was that number how much 25 billion 25
billion yeah [ __ ] okay you know what I
mean put them
we need to have some Gallows outside the
World Cup hang all the gays 25 billion I
felt gay
[ __ ] you Qatar suck my [ __ ] Jewish
dick that's kosher how about Banco this
coaster cooking [ __ ] [ __ ] y'all
seriously not trying to hear that
you know what I mean it's like oh well
you don't respect our culture we just
want to [ __ ] kill gay people and also
women uh women should be able to not go
to school and uh [ __ ] you know what I
mean trans people forget about that they
we just mashed them into [ __ ] glue we
didn't even ask questions
we have slaves I'm not respect to your
culture no
not
okay
being modest I get being mod you know
that's fine it's like okay you guys do
[ __ ] with that
you know no
let's not forget the West is not the
spokesman for Humanity should she suffer
I'm not whatever bro just don't kill gay
people [ __ ] you
this guy's a ballsy though to try this
though oh yeah
damn that guy's got balls of steel dude
and a killer hat that guy's got soccer
balls for balls you know what I mean oh
God I miss him this guy's bringing the
balls to the World Cup
that's the front of the ship that is a
friend of the show we love him so this
is him he's very oh
he's not verified or he is verified
he's real verified
damn I'm surprised it's kind of [ __ ]
crazy to see how many so many people
riding for this absolute bigot [ __ ]
I as a very rich Sultan oil Baron
[ __ ] freak with slaves I'm so glad to
see that they are killing the gay people
is that racist you that accent should I
not do that yeah probably not
um uh that guy deleted his tweet about
uh you killing yourself oh what happened
bro
we won't forget though pull it up
we won't forget
Kaya
kayak hey my name's Kaya and I tell
people that Kaya kill themselves
come on rim shot hit me with it baby
poof
yeah I don't have that on my soundboard
so I mean
um how about one of these
I'll take it 1 600 DPI I'll take some
deep behind you
Kai your [ __ ] just apologize you
[ __ ] loser
then bro I'll forgive you if you just
put your mouth back on Charlie's dick
never come up for air and just stay in
your [ __ ] spot where you belong it is
a crazy long penis the fact that you
have a career or Voice or anything is
honestly a goddamn Miracle of Charlie
Jesus Christ your Saint and savior
okay literally lying literally lay down
in his foyer as his carpet that's how
[ __ ] wow yeah like you think Charlie
has it for you
yeah Charlie socks yeah yeah
he seems a little too like down to earth
for foyer he's stacked bro he's got a
fight yeah suck a little bit of dick is
that just the entrance to your house I
mean that's a very like fancy entrance
yeah
do I have a foyer
doesn't all houses technically have
that's what I thought I should say I
thought I thought it was I could be
wrong I thought it was like a little bit
separate from the actual house like it's
a little in between area between like
the front and the actual front door well
according to Oxford uh an entrance hall
or other open area in a building used by
the public especially a hotel or theater
oh so that's before yeah yeah I don't
think he's got foyer money because that
would mean well he's like no Ethan you
need a foyer I don't have a foil I'm
down to earth bro people saying
Charlie's Warehouse definitely has it
yeah I'm a man of the people I ain't got
no foyer definitely if I did though Kai
you're welcome to lay yourself down like
a [ __ ] human carpet I can wipe my
feet on you
I'm not going to hook you up though
you're gonna have to suck Charlie dick
hey guys screenshot this don't forget
thanks thanks Ethan Klein don't forget
what Kaya's response was to uh him
talking [ __ ] and lying about me
we love Kaya he's a good man
with a red flag if he went over you got
red flags on his background check
please don't arm Kaia he's dangerous
ah that gets my dick hard that's it
thank you Kaya
appreciate you
good man so this is real real
interesting stuff though so yeah let's
see nothing to see here just men
policing what women wear at FIFA welcome
to Qatar unless you're a woman or lgbtq
or want to drink a beer or wave a flag
of Iran not the Islamic regime's flag
reflect your respect
I never got to finish this so profanity
not reflecting places of worship I'm
sorry about who's pointing at mosques
and laughing what the [ __ ] are you even
talking about look at this [ __ ] dude
they [ __ ] praying there like who does
that anyway l l Islam Islam Islam
yeah Loud Music and Sound dude just
don't be loud people get the most
annoying chord possible and just blow it
for a few hours
no dating y'all
okay
taking Pikachu no no laying down in a
sexy pose and uh taking photos no having
legs no drawing like one of your French
girls right
I guess you're not allowed to take
people's photos I don't know it's not
about without permission they're like
they're like we just brought like 20
million tourists
let's please be respectful and not take
pictures no vlogging no volume be quiet
keep to yourself no music no swearing no
alcohol and no gay people the most
important rule of all no gay people like
that's annoying bro this is real people
saying is this real this is real respect
reflect your respect
here you want me to reflect my respect
[ __ ] you
that was edgy damn dude that was [ __ ]
hey sorry guys that was nuts here's the
type of app of
um outfit you're not allowed to wear
I mean okay I mean
I think you gotta have a little leeway
honestly if you're inviting millions of
tourists from all around the world you
wanted this right you kind of expect
everyone
to like follow every tradition it's just
it's a little silly fire is going to
come out that butthole
you know
but okay and you guys do you
you do you
yes so they deleted the whole reflect
you're respecting huh just like Kaya
interesting I wonder what it means I
think he reflected
means something
did you where did you ever able to find
anything about the no Kosher food
well yeah I mean I found I found
articles again I just didn't yeah so
just read the excerpt I'm just curious
all right sure uh kosher food Band
guitar
uh so Qatar won't allow cooked kosher
food public Jewish prayer Jewish
organizations claim Qatar is breaking
its promise
on allowing any cooked kosher food to be
sold at the foreign
kosher food like really what could be
the problem with that what confused me
is I know that they're not exactly the
same but don't don't most uh Muslims
isn't it very similar kosher food is
blessed by a rabbi I see so it's just
the blessing part there's differences
like you can't mix cheese and meat but
otherwise there's it's very similar yeah
even some Muslims like a lot of people
in my family including myself like if
something's kosher like I consider hello
right and my family does yeah that was
always my understanding but I guess in
no culture food no practice and if
you're a Jew hide it we don't want to
know
huh because if someone finds out you're
a Jew bad things are gonna happen boy
but they just said you have to respect
places of worship there's a bit of
Hitler and everyone
is that [ __ ] crazy I'm sorry if you
want to be on the international stage
you can't be like don't be Jewish here
and don't be gay here it's [ __ ]
insane
Ohio Hitler Ohio Hitler Dan come on
that's not a good time was that even me
[ __ ]
according to other sources at an
estimated of more than ten thousand
religious Jews from Israel and around
the world they're expected to arrive
there see I don't understand how people
really love soccer man seriously it's
like holy [ __ ] you couldn't pay me to go
watch it it's on TV too you know when me
and Lena used to work at that restaurant
it was predominantly Middle Eastern
customers and oh my God like when it was
the World Cup that was hell hell for us
like non-stop oh my God
the Israelis loved the world cup though
that's the first time I ever watched it
was when I was living in Israel people
were going crazy for it
is that identity theft
oh
when they were playing the if they were
pretending to not be Jewish that is
identity theft that's literally fraud
yeah
also gay
right there left as fraud
it's not funny it's not a joke it's not
funny
uh how long we've been going
we've been going uh almost three hours
that's not long enough
uh it's not funny we got
to uh prep a bunch of stuff for tomorrow
so how long we've been going down good
if we could wrap it up soon
you got another show to do today yeah
you have another show to do today no I'm
gonna do it live tomorrow why don't you
do it like when you drive just record
your audio while you drive you're a
bunch of people that's pretty ghetto no
no it's cool that's pretty like I don't
know [ __ ] about this yeah exactly no I I
actually like the vibe like just I love
carpool seriously yes it just so like
you don't care at all
no it's nice you guys want a car Vlog or
you want me to actually do a live show
tomorrow morning
okay if you put it like that honestly
why don't you just like when you're
taking a [ __ ] when you're driving when
you're eating dinner
I don't know dude I think people have
been like that
people are saying do it live people are
saying Drive live I'm seeing car Vlog I
don't want you guys to know where I am
live with peace and love not you guys
but some people I don't want people to
know where I am
people are saying
car vibes
people are saying
people are always going to want to live
more
that's what people want
is so anyway
um I'm gonna I'm gonna tomorrow at 12
I'm gonna go live okay I'm gonna go live
we're gonna do our show live for members
please join us all members
um
so let's get out there and tomorrow so
yeah I'm gonna be have fun tomorrow and
then
um we'll come in here and film the
Thanksgiving special so I'll try to be
here like two yeah is that cool uh
sounds great
kind of great to me yeah we're just we
gotta we're gonna set up a hole
thing to have everybody around the table
like we did before and our crew has
grown since last year so oh my God more
people to Sweet and Ila's coming this
time by the way yeah so Ela who uh
wasn't there for the lap you lose last
year she'll be here this time so oh by
the way I want to give a shout out
didn't do that forgot to do it today
trading cards
oh yeah podcast X trading cards are up
for not that much longer I think uh oh
[ __ ] well it has another week or
something right yeah I believe so so
you guys can get it it's 25 bucks it's
available through like the beginning of
December
they're awesome the cards are don't
scroll oh the prolapse is in this
summer he needs like a safer work one
for me to show on the podcast it's
technically blurred
that's not enough yeah if you can see
red I don't know I saw red
but uh yeah the cards are still up there
guys grab them before the opportunities
look at that look at that my mom ordered
dude
that's cool how he took my prolapse card
I don't have a prolapse card we have
extra ones Kim oh well you know I think
I can live without that one but uh I
think it's in better handling
I need a prolapse card yeah you need the
whole collection cam what are you
talking about why would you sit out
don't be silly I don't know okay I'll
take a prolapse or two I'll give you a
bro take a prolapse
don't be shy don't come on you know what
give me that prolapse guys there you go
give him the pro lights
we have a whole bunch of prolapses all
right anyway I want to do one more okay
the people that deserve money
uh e how do you say that name
Isis Isis no maybe well that is a name
wait Isis but I don't know if that's
it's i x i s well anyway shout out they
said yo I love y'all that's it thank you
Legend we love you ow ow all right let
me do one more there's one I've been
wanting to do for a while actually I'll
give you guys a choice I have the crazy
chemical peel Tick Tock clinic this [ __ ]
is nuts
or I've got this guy that says every
woman has a r word fantasy this guy's a
[ __ ]
super creep that one's
definitely the chemical peel between
those two that one's just disturbing
yeah and it's just that's too much and
ending on that seems like why do we want
to just suddenly bring down those be
safe all right see ya what do we do
about it yeah
all right let's do the chemical peel
this one I've been wanting to do for a
while so I saw this on my Tick Tock page
as all good things happen in life and it
absolutely blew my [ __ ] mind now
maybe some of you ladies out there are
know about this stuff
um but I have never seen anything like
this
um it's in Spanish uh probably illegal
to do in America
oh my God you guys oh my god do people
do this in America
um I mean I know that this one after I
finished Accutane my dermatologist
mentioned something about CO2 laser
which does burn the top layer of your
skin but the healing process is not this
brutal they yeah they do do it in
America but not to this degree is what I
understand yeah and also this does not
last as soon as she goes in the sun
she's [ __ ] is also my understanding
just ask jayvano
my skin is feeling great it's never felt
better
um dude it looks like they shoved her
face into a campfire this is insane you
guys
yeah so I take enjoy uh
wow God that looks so painful so bad so
horrific ugh girl right there it's all
red because they have on their Tick Tock
like videos of them like actually
peeling the skin right I wanted to show
that is that in the dark it's it's kind
of brutal but I can link you yeah I want
to I want to see that gosh
she don't look good it looks like her
face is like red like look how red like
is that supposed to look good I don't
know
there's another example if you want to
pull it up while Olivia's grabbing that
yeah
you ever seen that I don't know
so uh it's a peel called peeling day
feno profundo
which translates to deep fennel peel
fennel peel is the deepest most
effective type of chemical appeal most
effective is debatable
The Tick Tock page is called Clinica
harmonia located in Brazil
yeah I have in Brazil they just get
weird and wild out there
I have a feeling
um oh my God look at the doctor's
website he's
look at this [ __ ] he's [ __ ] twirling
the um syringe look at this like he's a
cowboy this is like a super basic uh
template is my guess that they're using
but none of these doctors work there
oh you think it's just it looks like
story blocks wait really
definitely my guess what
why the [ __ ] would you have someone like
doing a loop-de-loop with a syringe like
their goddamn
Doc Holiday like yo I want your ass
steady and holding that [ __ ] not
playing games
yo I think you're right these are just
story blocks yeah it's probably some
older but here they are all together now
uh they they have the logo on their
shirts you can see I think it's real
these people make so much money maybe
they invest like crazy like these people
are probably all like super millionaires
I even catch the logo yeah but let's see
yeah no they're really them
then take a look at this would you want
let this guy give you plastic surgery
watch
wait look at this he does a [ __ ]
trick shot with a syringe he [ __ ]
it's kind of cool does he work for dude
perfect that's how he did sick yo that's
how he does it he's like all right we're
gonna do the botox right here all right
here we go
Kobe trick shot Kobe yeah
crazy right that's the people who do in
the chemical peel all right check this
[ __ ] out guys check this [ __ ] out y'all
oh my God that isn't too much for
YouTube I mean it's just a medical
procedure is it I mean it is I mean it's
just a layer of skin but it is I mean
there's no blood it's a medical
procedure it's not okay
I don't think it is but I guess I won't
risk it y'all got me paranoid but I
think it's fine it's educational there's
no blood it's not violent it's a medical
procedure and it's not showing Jenna
those are things I face
um but here's one with 7.6 million views
oh my God lady
this poor woman
you're old just be old damn
oh my God they scared her oh God
y'all paid for that
foreign
look at this [ __ ] oh God
bruh you paid for that lady
yeah okay before
hag old hag
after
looking like a president I mean okay
first of all yes the difference she has
no wrinkles and [ __ ] but you can tell
her skin is still like acid peeled like
it's still red and [ __ ] it's gonna
also as far as I'm aware when you get a
facial appeal you're really not supposed
to tug at the skin like you can maybe
trim it to keep it from getting in your
way but like you're not you're not
supposed to tear flaps of meat off your
[ __ ] face I know right who would have
known dude it reminds me in Back to the
Future too when doc pulls off his skin
he's like oh I got some procedure from
the future that made me look like 40
years younger this was it yeah
Chelsea says this is very real when I
worked in sales multiple people I worked
with did this man but so
it can't last like more than a little
amount of time right
I think it does I think it it's very
susceptible to skin damn uh sun damage
but
yeah it I mean it helps just Beauty at
what cost
you lose a part of your soul yo crazy
though Ben Franklin actually got a crazy
redo on this yeah no he looks really
fired because Ben Franklin's what like
three 400 years old oh my God look at
his skin you know what's really crazy
too is um giving Ben Franklin the the
procedure actually
made her out of focus which is really
interesting and like washed her out a
little bit wow I mean her face is red as
[ __ ] if anything they put makeup to make
her look like she didn't just have her
face
like spilled off by acetone and for one
like I I literally think on the left
they sharpened it like yeah hella
contrast yeah and then in the right one
I mean look at her hair like you can see
it's the focus is soft it's like kind of
blurry super tons of contrast oh yeah
her hair is all blurred yeah mad respect
that woman's been through a lot
with peace and love it's like okay I'm
not going to be mean
she's beautiful
uh oh her face must hurt though she's
beautiful
just age just accept it lady here's
before and after
that someone said the Aging is
transferred to a painting of yourself
hidden somewhere
wow that's good that's good by the way
whatever this is I'm feeling it
[Music]
this is the it won't load so it's just
showing this I'm liking what I'm seeing
ow
you've got an eye is like the uh the old
uh okay here Alchemist woman in the
forest oh my God why are you yeah why
peel the skin off that's gotta feel so
[ __ ] bad
that is such a nightmare I've never seen
so here's the before now all right good
let's see
yeah so look how she looks here she
looks old and she looks like
she's [ __ ] a burn victim who's about
to die yeah
[Laughter]
I just don't understand this is not
better she looks like
[ __ ] up
that would scare me if I saw someone
like that on the street totally what if
I saw myself
like that during the healing I would be
so scared okay so imagine Grandma coming
home like that I dreamed I saw my
maternal ground hold on hold on I'm
sitting by the bank of a swimming pool
go on which was also a river
her genital region was exposed dimly it
had the appearance of a thick mat of
hair
she was stroking herself absent-mindedly
right and [ __ ] you if you don't like it
that was good thank you I didn't know it
was going to work I got nervous up there
it took me for a Twist so here's old ass
[ __ ] lame grandma-faced lamo L Lama
and here is goddamn Beetlejuice
afterlife looking [ __ ]
what the [ __ ] is this [ __ ] that's not
better
shrunken head dude it's not better it
looks like she have witchcraft done in a
bad way
like she looks like a real person at
least now it's like there's something
deeply wrong with you and I don't know
what it is
like uncanny [ __ ] it looks like a finger
dipped in acid
no fingerprints anymore right right
right right right well
all smooth
that's crazy
so I thought you guys would enjoy that I
was yeah yeah I did Gob smacked by that
one dude the slow-mo of the guy flipping
the syringe and smiling I know so epic I
know man I want a trick shot of of uh
Botox in my face yeah
you wanna see it again I sure do
where is it
um here's their website
okay get ready guys
it is
the crew's all here my man
I don't
need a reality show
that's actually a good point
this literally looks like the
what's it called selling Sunset like
intros they're definitely giving
I'm laughing
you know what they need
that's good they need to stop laughing
at Sonic besides of that
they need to take the syringes and play
darts with it all right and then they
said they go we'll give you free Botox
if you let us use your face as a
dartboard
but they're that good wow
I've been trying to find an opening all
episode to use that and we're getting to
the end and I think my hand just
twitched and I hit it so I apologize but
it's good I really wanted to that's a
new Boby drop for everybody let's hear
it again
so is he a real Sonic fan oh yeah oh
yeah
but he's he's doing he's doing that
stick right uh in that in that part yeah
probably he's kind of leaned into the
whole yeah it's funny I mean yeah I'm
glad he leaned into it got a better
sense of humor than most of those other
[ __ ] idiots
stop laughing I mean I mean I'll give
him credit for that
I love Bobby though this guy Beau blex
he's like a small YouTuber who's part of
like this whole click of people that
hate me
and he he showed the clip of uh what we
said about Ben Shapiro and he got [ __ ]
we talked about it he got suspended bro
he got [ __ ] since he got his scragged
for showing it I thought that was so
funny
that's so funny I wish Ben Shapiro got
suspended for showing up because he
showed the clip
all right that's enough that's enough
thank you guys
what a fun time huh
a good time we had here
really it's just so much fun
hey uh maybe we can do a segment where I
do a I get a syringe and do trick shots
on your guys's faces
thoughts
or take a blow toast to your face as
part of a facial treatment will you have
a hyperbaric chamber waiting yes I will
of course I will we can talk about it
I'll wrap you up in bandages and put
them on Wiki feet
all right guys it's uh been a great day
thank you all for being here it's been
such a fun good episode love y'all
we'll be back on Wednesday for episode
as usual tomorrow for members who I love
we'll be going live at 12 with peace and
love
and um back on Friday with our
Thanksgiving special so we got a whole
week planned
good times huh
all right see you guys on Wednesday or
actually see members tomorrow but anyway
that's it all right thank you all
yeah man yeah you ain't kidding all
right
[Music]
three thousand two hundred DPI
6400 DPI
[Music]
foreign
[Music]